REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING A JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS BEFORE WE
BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING. WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THERE IS AN
AUTHOR POLL FOR FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE THIS IS AB SEVEN
ZERO TWO BY SANTIAGO AGAIN AN
AUTHOR PULL FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE A. B. SEVEN ZERO TWO
SANTIAGO DUE TO THE CONTINUED
STATE HOME ORDERS WERE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE THE COMMITTEE ROOMS AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. FOR
WITNESSES WISHING TO DIAL IN
WILL BE USING A MODERATE A
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY TO
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN.
AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE IS. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS
WELL AS YOUR TELEPHONE SCREEN
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE A TELEPHONE
SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE THREE THREE ZERO
ONE. AND OUR STAFF WILL BE ABLE
TO HELP YOU. COLLEAGUES OF. WE
HAVE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT ARE. ON CONSENT THAT
IS AB THREE FIFTY SIX BY
SEPTEMBER CHEN AB FOUR FORTY
THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER CARILLO.
AB EIGHT THIRTY BY SOMEONE OUR
FLORA AB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
EIGHTY NINE FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN. AB TEN
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FONG AND AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR
BY THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE WHICH WAY TAKING UP
ONCE A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
IT'S SAYING THAT WE'RE ACTING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND THAT WE
HAVE MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WITHIN BEGIN. TODAY'S COMMITTEE
HEARING AND WILL BE OPERATING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE FOR THE TIME
BEING. AND WILL BEGIN TO FALL
ORDER AND I SEE THAT WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR HERE. AND THIS THEN WILL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN ZERO TWO BY SAM
AMERICORPS AGAIN FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN YEAR TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COURT CENTER
COURT PLEASE FEEL FREE PERCENT
WHENEVER READY GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR. FOR
HIS ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE
AND ALSO THANK COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL. IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
BUREAUOF CANNABIS CONTROL
INDUCTED REGULATIONS TO CLARIFY
PORTION OF THE LANGUAGE ADOPTED
IN PROP SIXTY FOUR WITH RESPECT
TO BILLBOARD ADVERTISING.
LANGUAGE IN THE PROPOSITIONS
STATES THE LICENSEE SHALL NOT
ADVERTISED ON A BILLBOARD OR
SIMILAR ADVERTISING DEVICE
LOCATED ONINTERSTATE HIGHWAY
OR IN THE STATE. OFF HIGHWAY
WHICH CROSSES CALIFORNIA
BORDER- THIS IS STRANGE
LANGUAGE BECAUSE STATE HIGHWAYS
DON'T CROSS THE BORDER. AND
IT'S VERY HARD TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT MEANS. THE BUREAU
CONCLUDED THAT PROP SIXTY FOUR
DOES NOT CLARIFY TO WHAT EXTENT
SUCH PROHIBITIONS WOULD TAKE
PLACE- AND THEY DECIDED THAT A
FIFTEEN MILE RADIUS FOR ANY
HIGHWAY THAT GOES TO THE BORDER
OF WEST APPROPRIATE. WHEN THE
BEARS REGULATIONS WERE
CHALLENGED IN COURT YOUR ARGUED
THE PRIMARY INTENT OF THE
HIGHWAY LANGUAGE IN PROP SIXTY
FOUR WAS TO AVOID RUNNING AFOUL
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
CONTINUED. CLASSIFICATION OF
CANNABIS AS A SCHEDULE ONE
CONTROLLED DEVICE SO THE IDEA
WAS- THAT YOU WOULDN'T
ADVERTISE IN ANOTHER STATE-
CANNABIS ADVERTISING IS ALREADY
EXTREMELY RESTRICTED IN
CALIFORNIA. STATUTE AND
REGULATIONS SPECIFY THAT
ADVERTISEMENTS CANNOT BE
ATTRACTIVE TO AN AUDIENCE UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE. INCLUDES
A PROHIBITION ON CONTACT
CARTOON CHARACTERS IMAGES OF
ANYONE UNDER TWENTY ONE AND
TOYS- THE DECISION ISSUED BY
THE JUDGE IN THE FORMER CASE-
PROHIBITS. ALL ADVERTISING ON
INTERSTATE HIGHWAYS SUCH AS I.
FIVE AND FIVE EIGHTY BECAUSE
THEY CROSSED THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER HOWEVER IT DOESN'T
PROHIBIT IT ON. TWO EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY AT SEVERAL-
IT IS NOT A LOGICAL
INTERPRETATION WE'VE TALKED TO
THE LAWYERS IN THIS CASE- WHO
WERE LOOKING AT THE PROPOSITION
THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW THIS.
LANGUAGE GOT THERE AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE INTENT WAS.
IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT CLOSING
THE DOOR ON THE ILLICIT MARKET
WHICH IS WHERE MINERS GET THE
ACCESS TO CANNABIS WITH UNKNOWN
CONTAMINANTS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A LITTLE LEGAL
MARKET THAT WILL GROW THRIVE
OUTCOMPETE THE ILLEGAL MARKET.
AB THIRTEEN OH TWO DOES THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO TURN OVER. ALL
THE PRESENTATION NOW TO MY
WITNESSES AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF. CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND MEGAN
LOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION THANK
YOU CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DR COURT NOW WILL OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THERE ARE TWO AND WILL LIMIT
THE TESTIMONY PER INDIVIDUAL TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES AND WE
BEGIN WITH MS JENKINS- YES YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY-MEMBER CLERK FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND FOR BRINGING THE
ISSUE FORWARD. ANY CAN FINALLY
HAPPEN THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OTO WIN
VOTERS APPROVED PROP SIXTY FOUR
THE ESTABLISHED A FRAMEWORK FOR
COMMERCIAL. SALES IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING A PATHWAY FOR LEGAL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES ADVERTISE
ON BILLBOARDS SUBJECT TO
CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS AND ADDS
IN THE- AUTHOR AB STATED- THE
BUREAU FURTHER IMPLEMENTED THE
INITIATIVE BY. THE FIFTEEN MILE
RADIUS- HOWEVER THE RECENT
COURT DECISION- THAT THE BTC
EXTENDED IT AT FLORIO TEN BUT
THE- HI RESULT IN CANADA THE
NOTHING NOW BEING. FROM AFRICA
ON A INNER HIGH THAT THE STATE
FOR. AND LIKE FEES WITH THE
BILL NOT BEGIN. OF REMOVING
THAT THE TENDERS OF THE ONLY
POP REALLY CANADA OPERATOR TO
ASK. THEIR BUSINESS BUT ONLY
THREE TO UNDERMINE THE-
INDUSTRY BUT STRENGTHENING THE
A LOOK AT MARKET CAN TO OUT
NUMBER OP. BY ABOUT TO ONE I
KNOW THAT WE LYFT FANS CANNABIS
BILLABLE ADVERT AND HOW. ALL
HAS THE MOST RESTRICTIVE BILL
FOR ADVERT LINE AND RIGHT. IN
THE NAY. THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
STRICTLY TO BE APPLIED AND
TAKES A VERY. AB THIRTEEN OH
TWO. YOU DID PRETTY OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR I CLEARLY S. IN. THE
FIFTEEN ACT PROBATE. PREVIOUSLY
FORTH AND REGULAR. FROM THE-
AUTHORITY WITH TO ON TO CARRY
OUT THE BOX AND LICENSEES THE
ABILITY ADVERTISE ON. IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE STATE
STREET ADVERTISING. HE STRONG
GREG CAN INDUSTRY AS WELL OF
CAL CLARA TOOL TO REDUCE
LICENSED BACK. I'M ACCESSING
CANNABIS. THEREFORE FROM THE. I
MAKE IN MY PROGRAM BRADFORD THE
CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR ADVERTISING.
YES NO MAYES MEMBERSHIP
INCLUDES THE INDUSTRY'S
SMALLEST AND LARGEST COMPANIES
OVER 90% OF CALIFORNIA'S
LICENSED ONSITE SIGNS ARE
OPERATED BY OUR MEMBERS. I'M AT
ALL THEY DID ARE YOU NOT IN
THEIR UNANIMOUS FOR AB THIRTEEN
ISSUE EVEN OUT OF MEMBERS WHO
DO NOT CURRENTLY AND CANNABIS
ADS. ALL FINER RECOGNIZE THAT
BANNING AVERAGE FOR LEGAL WITH
CORRECT A LAB. OTHER STATES A
APART RESEARCH REALLY FABRIC OF
SECTOR PRODUCTS. HOWEVER NOT A
STATE HAVE NOW RIGHT BILL FOR
BAND WERE TO THE ALBERTA AND
CAN'T. OUTDOOR AS AND CANNABIS.
ARE ALREADY EXTREMELY
RESTRICTED IN CALIFORNIA WITH
COMPREHENSIVE STANDARDS THAT
INCLUDE THE OPENING SIZE HI
FACING LANDSCAPING AND SCENIC
HIGHWAY PROHIBIT. I STATURE IT
REGULAR ARE ALL CLEAR THE WAR
THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN
PROTECTING SHE FROM. THAT WOULD
APPEALING TO ANYONE UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE. WITHOUT
ADVERTISING CANADA INDUSTRY.
HAVE COMPLY WITH THE BC HE-
pTASK WHEN. THE REGULAR TO AND
AMPLE THE HUNDRED PAGE VOTER
PROPER THAT. IN THINKING ABOUT
THE RIGHTS OF LIFE TO FAIRLY
THE CLEAR LANG WITHOUT CREAM
THE FIFTY MILE BACK UP AND THE
BOY. WITHOUT YOU IMAGINE THAT A
LIFE WITH. OKAY NEAR FOR A FIVE
HOUR. BUT I SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HERE I'VE COULD NOT ABIDE BY
REACHES THE ORGAN HUNDRED OF
MILES. ADDITIONALLY AT THE
STATE ALL OF NEIGHBORING HAVE A
CANNABIS SO CAN REALLY TO CAN'T
TOWARD BOARD CROSSING HAVE BEEN.
AB THIRTY THAT YOU WILL SOLVE
SUPERIOR COURT CONCERNED THE
REGULAR WAS IN CONTRAST MODESTO.
BY CODIFY THE REGULAR. THE PRE
REGULAR BUT NOT SHALLOW BY THE
CANNABIS OR OUT TO INDUSTRY ON
HOW TO. GROUNDS WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE CORRECTION THAT IN
THE WITHIN I DON'T FOR BACK.
WHICH WILL COST RESTORATION FOR
BOTH ADVOCATE AND THE- ARE
CANNABIS BETWEEN. WITH MEETING
AFTER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS
LONG DEALS THE RETIRE CHIEF
COUNSEL CAL. WHO HAS FORTY
YEARS AGO. IN BILLBOARD. ISSUES
YES NO WAY PROUD TO. THEIR OH
TWO. A CRITICAL TOOL FOR THE
LICENSE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
COMPETE TO COMPETE WITH THE-
MARC. WE WERE. ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE THE YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC TESTING
FOR PER. WIN ASSISTANCE. OUR
WOULD YOU OPEN UP THE LINE NOW
FOR. AN ADDITIONAL OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT SIMPLY BY. SAYING
GIVING US THEIR NAME AND IF
ELATION. IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
AN APPLICATION. THIS IS IN
SUPPORT. SEVEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
OUR TESTIFIED PRESS ONE AND
THEN ACTIVE TIME AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO TO SUPPORT. OKAY I'M A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION ON THE-
AND I'LL GO AHEAD LOCAL LINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MR CHIU
MEMBERS AND LYNN PEDIATRIC AND
SEE BY A COUPLE CAL THAT. AND
CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT UCSF DOT
SUPERMARKET DOCTOR SILVER IF I
COULD ON HAVE YOU CLAWS WE'RE
THE PORTION OF THE CAN FOR- IN
WISHING SIGNIFY THEIR SUB. SO
AGAIN THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE OPERATOR TO OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
FILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO
ASSEMBLY. BILL. THIRTEEN ZERO
TWO. MY PART AND AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT
YOU'RE OVERLAND ONE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M I'M ALL
RIGHT I HAD THE WRONG NUMBER
WELL WHAT WHAT. NUMBER TO CALL
IN FOR OPPOSITION. OPERATOR
AGAIN THIS IS FOR THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT ON
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN ZERO TWO.
AND AGAIN TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK. DAGAALKA LINE OF FORTY
THREE GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT.
FORTY THREE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CLINT
OLIVIER I'M THE CEO OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUSINESS
FEDERATION BIZ FAD. WE WERE ON
A BUSINESS COALITION LETTER
SUPPORTING AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
BUT WANTED TO ADD THAT WE ALSO
SUPPORT THIS ITEM ON BEHALF OF
OUR SEVENTY MEMBERS THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE WILL LINE. MY MOM HERE
GO TO LINE OF SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOR HELLO MY LINE OF
ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS INCREASE STRATEGY
REPRESENTING FOLLOWING BILL
WOULD COME SUPPORTED THIRTEEN
TO TOMORROW HAVE A- GET A
OUTDOOR. BILL OUTDOOR. IN
MEADOW OUT APPETITE THANK YOU.
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN EMBERS THIS IS
MARK BURKE AT WITH THE M.
ABBOTT THE ON BEHALF OF COOLEY
CHANNEL OUT. BILLBOARD COMPANY
IN OF THE BILL THANK YOU. AND
WE'LL TRY ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA STRONG SO
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ONE OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME A NUMBER OF
MY NAME IS CAITLYN O'NEILL
WHICH USE TECHNOLOGY CALL INTO
OF THE BILL. IT LINE ONE EIGHT
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR SHARON MEMBERS JASON BRYANT
ON BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
ZERO TWO THANK YOU. SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
GOLDMAN I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER OF
THE PRIMARY DEMOCRATIC WELL.
OUR CLUB IS STRONGLY IN FAVOR
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HILLARY
HER ERA. YEAH USER SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IT'LL- MORE WATER UNDER THE
TERMS STRANGER THE PROPOSAL
TIME AND CLOSER WE CALL THEM.
SEVENTY NINE IF I HAD. RIGHT.
PARTY NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO NINETEEN LABOR
HAMMER. HELLO HI MANY ASSEMBLY
ABRAHAM REPRESENTATIVES TO
DISCUSS CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
OUR HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS ACROSS
VARIOUS INDUSTRIES AND WE
SUPPORT. THAT CAN HELP YOU
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME.
WHAT YOUR DOCTOR OR LINE ONE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CARE MY NAME IS HEIDI
WHAT MEN ARE BEHALF THE SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER OF AMERICANS FOR
SAFE ACCESS REPRESENTING TWO
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN AT HIM. THANK YOU.
DR. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING I'M
GONNA LOVE THAT OF THE CANNABIS
SOCIAL EQUITY BRANDS- FLOWER WE
WERE ASKED AND THEN PEOPLE
GIVING TESTIMONY HERE TO
REPRESENT THE SOCIAL EQUITY
COMPANIES THAT CAN OFFER IN
OPPOSED. LANDING. I COUPLE FOR
THROUGH MEANS THE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OP NEXT ONLY THREE.
THE ONE A FOUR YEAR LINE IS. HI
MY NAME TERRY BEEN INTO BLOOM
REP TO NINE EMPLOYEE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN AFTER. RIGHT
MESSINGER LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE CALL. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KELLY THE OF FOUNDER
LOOKING VALLEY CANNABIS
ALLIANCE WE HAVE ABOUT A
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THANK YOU NOTES.
THANK YOU. I NEED. YOU NOT
ACTING OUT OF THE- I NEED THE
NAME OF THE BILL. OPERATOR AT
ONE TWENTY EIGHT ARE YOU SEE ME
OPERATOR WOULD YOU MIND JUST
CHECKING TO ENSURE THAT ALL
LINES ARE CLOSED AND THAT WE
HAVE A EASY FACILITATION OF THE
NEXT CALLER AND THAT WE ME TOO
ALL LINES SO THAT WE DON'T HEAR
BACKGROUND NOISE INCLUDING
BIRDS ARE AND ARE BARKING DOGS.
THANK YOU AGAIN LATER JOHN PETE
PLEASE MUTE YOUR LINE THAT'S
NOT. IN YOUR INCLUDING OUR
WITNESSES- RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE
LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT OPEN. HI
I'M LAURA FOGELMAN ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL CANNABIS FOR CONSUMER
SAFETY COALITION I'M PRESENTING
ON BEHALF OF OUR LARGE
COLLECTION OF LICENSED CANNABIS
BUSINESSES AND ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING PAX LABS. MARIJUANA
POLICY PROJECT YOUR LEADS AND
FIFTY FIVE OTHER BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN OUT OF JAIL THANK YOU.
IT WILL LOOK OUT NOT ALIGN
NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAMELA LOPEZ WITH T.
THREE CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN OUT TO. OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COLORS
ON. PARDON ME UP YOU ARE
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME THIS
WAS THE IN SUPPORT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU JUST DO ONE FINAL
CALL FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK INCIDENTS ARE
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU LIKE
TO SUPPORT IT ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. M. ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT.
AND A LINE OF SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS. OKAY.
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT CALLER.
CURRENTLY NO NINE IN Q. HERE.
GREAT AND JUST AS A REMINDER
PLEASE BE SURE TO MEET YOUR
LINES IF YOU'RE CURRENTLY
CALLED IN AT THIS MOMENT IN
TIME. THAT WILL MOVE ON TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. OPERATOR UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS ONE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AND WILL THEN GO TO
A DOCTOR SILVER DR SILVER
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
MOAN THE- WORD IN TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR LYNN
SILVER PEDIATRICIAN AND SENIOR
ADVISER AT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE. OF CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT UCSF REPRESENTING
OUR CONCERNS. I HAVE MANY
ISSUES BROUGH UP SURROUNDED BY
TOBACCO BILLBOARDS ONLY THE
TOBACCO MASTER SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT DOCTORS OUT OF OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN
SWAYS. ALLOWING CANNABIS
BILLBOARDS BACK ON OUR HIGHWAYS
WAS A HISTORIC REGULATORY
FALLOUT. IT BROKE PROP SIXTY
FOUR PROMISES TO VOTERS TOLD
THAT THE STATE WOULD IMPLEMENT
THE STATE OF THE NATION'S
STRICTEST CHILD PROTECTIONS.
INCLUDING ADVERTISING AND
BILLBOARD RESTRICTIONS. THIS
PROMISE WAS BROKEN BY STATE
REGULATIONS NEARLY IDENTICAL TO
AB THIRTEEN OH TWO. RECENTLY
HELP VIOLATE STATE LAW BY THE
COURT. BY THE BLATANT EXAMPLE
OF REGULATORY CAPTURE NOT
CLARIFICATION WITHIN AFFECT.
THE STATE CAN. LIKELY BE AT OUR
REQUEST AND ACTING UPON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF ITS
COMMITTEE ON HOUSTON PUBLIC
HEALTH. RECOMMENDED RETURNED TO
THE LANGUAGE OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR. BILLBOARDS ARE NOT NEEDED
FOR SUCCESSFUL LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AND IT IS. TRUE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE LAWS IN THE NATION.
OR THE BILLBOARD. RESTRICTIONS
DON'T EXIST ELSEWHERE. CANCER
RECENTLY A 8% IN IN CANNABIS
YOU BY. CHANGED TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY NINETEEN. THIS IS
NOT AN ACCEPTABLE OUTCOME OUR
KIDS ARE GOING TO SCHOOL HIGHER
GETTING HIGH SCHOOL. A PROBLEM
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL IN THE STATE
IS SEEING. THEIR SHOWING UP IN
THE ER WITH CANNABIS RELATED
PSYCHOSIS FROM ALT APPROPRIATE
PRODUCTS LIKE PRETTY BATES
ADVERTISED ON OUR HIGHWAYS. AND
ALL OF YOU SAW OUR HIGHWAYS
WERE LITTERED IN CANADA SAID TO
EXPOSING MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN IN. EVERY DAY ON THEIR
WAY TO SCHOOL OR HOME. THIS IS
WELL DOCUMENTED TO INCREASE
USED INTERESTS AND USED IN
THESE PRODUCTS. BY OTHER MEDIA
CAN USE AUDIO COMP- ORIENTS
COMPOSITION DATA THERE IS NO.
BILLBOARDS WITHOUT USING
EXPOSURE. THE SCHOOL BOARD TO
INCLUDED VISUAL THAT IMITATE
OKAY. DISBELIEF FLAVOR PRODUCTS
KNOWN TO ATTRACT HOUSTON
RECENTLY BANNED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE FOR
TOBACCO. IMPLIED COLUMNS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE CAN BE SOLVED BY A
DISPENSARY OR PROMISE
HAPPINESS. EXCEPT FOR THOSE
EXAMPLES IN MY LETTER. ALLOWING
SAFER LEGAL ACCESS IS NOT
REQUIRED SPENDING ONE HUNDRED
AND USED TO BILLBOARDS. THAT IS
A BLATANT FALSEHOODS. WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE NAY
ON A. B. THIRTEEN OH TWO AND TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES TO ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHICH IS
BEGIN OPPOSITION SIMPLY BY
SIGNIFYING THEIR OPPOSITION. I
NAY MANIPULATION IF THEY WISH
TO DO SO. THANK YOU YOU'LL WANT
TO PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE CAN FIRST GO TO LINE OF
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
MADELINE COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET MORE ON THE HAWKINS
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
THIRTEEN OH TWO THANK YOUNG. I
MEAN ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BONTA LINE ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS ERICA LEARY ON BEHALF
OF THE NORTH COASTAL PREVENTION
COALITION IN NORTH SAN DIEGO
COUNTY CALLING INSTEAD FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TO
PROTECT OUR YOUTHFROM
BILLBOARD ADVERTISING OF
CANNABIS. WHEN NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
KATIE STRANG EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN MARCOS PREVENTION
COALITIONS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN OH TWO THANK YOU.
I KNOW FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEEN OUR DIGITAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS ARE ON THE PHONE
LINES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA PAUSE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. LOW HERE FLORETTE HERE
ARAMBULA BERMAN BLOOM CHEN CHIU
CUNNINGHAM DALLY FONG GIPSON
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN RT MEDINA.
MULLIN SALAS CAME. TEN MEMBERS
PRESENTLY OF A QUORUM ESTABLISH
TWENTY WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM- WILL NOW BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AND
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME FROM ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DR KIRTI WHICH TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU. THE LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ALREADY
FOLLOWS THE STRICTEST
GUIDELINES. TO PREVENT YOUTH
ACCESS TO CANNABIS. LEGAL
CANNABIS THROAT SOLD THROUGH
LICENSED RETAILERS IS AMONG THE
MOST HIGHLY REGULATED CONSUMER
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA. STATE
LAW AND THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL- HAVE REGULATIONS
PROHIBITING ADVERTISING IN A
MANNER INTENDED TO ENCOURAGE
PERSONS UNDER TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF AGE TO CONSUME CANNABIS OR
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. ARE
PROHIBITED A LICENSEE FROM
PUBLISHING OR DISSEMINATING
ADVERTISING OR MARKETING THIS
TRACTOR CHILDREN- IT ALSO-
PROHIBITS DEPICTIONS OF OR
IMAGES OF MINORS OR ANYONE
UNDER TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE-
AND IT PROHIBITS THE USE OF
OBJECTS SUCH AS TOYS
INFLATABLES MOVIE CHARACTERS.
CARTOON CHARACTERS OR ANY OTHER
DISPLAY DEPICTION OR IMAGE-
DESIGNED IN ANY MANNER LIKELY
TO BE APPEALING TO MINORS OR
ANYONE UNDER TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF AGE. ACCORDING TO A MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE STUDY BY THE
INSURANCE INSTITUTE FOR HIGHWAY
SAFETY- ALMOST ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. SAID THAT
THE UNDER AGE USERS IN THEIR
JURISDICTION GOT THEIR
MARIJUANA FROM UNLICENSED
SELLERS AND NEARLY A THIRD SAID
THAT THE ILLICIT MARKET HAS
GROWN- WE HAVE A REAL PROBLEM
HERE. WE HAVE A LEGAL INDUSTRY
WHICH WILL NOT SELL TO PEOPLE
UNDER TWENTY ONE AND IT ILLEGAL
INDUSTRY WHICH IS CONSIDERABLY
HIGHER WE NEED THAT LEGAL
INDUSTRY WHICH WILL NOT SELL TO
YOUNGSTERS WE NEED THAT LEGAL
INDUSTRY TO GROW THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE THAT'S WHY I'M CALLING FOR
A PROPER INTERPRETATION OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DR CLARK AS YOU YOU
KNOW THAT WHO AT ONE POINT IN
TIME WE HAD TWO CONFLICTING
BILLS BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE- BUT
I ALSO HAD THE PLEASURE TO MEET
WITH YOU IN YOUR DISTRICT TO
IRON OUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND UNDERSTAND LEGISLATIVE
INTENT I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
EQUALLY COMMITTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE INTO THIS BODY AND
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. TO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR GRAHAM
MILLISECOND BY MISTER GIBSON
THREE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB THIRTEEN OH TO COURT
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA BY FLORA HI
ARAMBULA. MERIMBULA HEIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN I FLEW. CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM DELLY
DELLY IPHONE. FONG HI GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. HOLDEN
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA. MEDINA HI
MULLIN SALAS TAKING. NINE I.
ZERO NOTICE NINE EYES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR WORK
COLLEAGUES WILL NOW GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE
FEEL FREE 2% WHATEVER READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
IS INTENDED TO EXTEND THE
ACCREDITATION DEADLINE FOR
DENTAL SCHOOLS FROM JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR.
TWO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY THIRTY.
THE REASON FOR THIS EXTENSION
IS BECAUSE PURSUANT TO AB
FIFTEEN NINETEEN PASSED BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. THE GRADATION OF FOR
DENTAL SCHOOLS WHICH IS USED TO
BE PERFORMED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL BOARD WAS TRANSFERRED TO
THE COMMISSION OF DENTAL
CREATION. OF THE EIGHTY A ALSO
KNOWN AS CODA. THE LEGISLATION
ALSO PROVIDED SCHOOLS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY ACCREDITED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL BOARD HAD TO
BE COMPLETE. AT COMPLETED CODE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS BY JAN
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR
ACCREDITATION. NOW LET ME JUST
SAY POINT OUT SOME OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT I BELIEVE WE HAVE
A POINT OF DIFFERENCE IN THAT
IS THAT- THE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT THAT THERE IS. A TIME FRAME
TO COMPLETE THE FORM SCHOOL
ACCREDITATION THAT- ARE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION AND THE
OPINION IS BASED ON POINTTWO
DOCUMENTATION. ARE BASED ON THE
ACCREDITATION OF THE SAUDI
ARABIAN SCHOOL THAT STARTED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. AND DID NOT
ACHIEVE ITS ACCREDITATION
UNTIL. ELEVEN YEARS LATER-
DOCUMENTATION HAS BEEN PROVIDED
FOR ME TO SHARE WITH MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IF ALL WANTING TO
SEE THAT SO BASED ON THAT-
THERE'S A FEELING THAT THE NEED
FOR AN EXTENSION- FOR THE
SCHOOL. IS A VITALLY NECESSARY.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO IS ABOUT
PROVIDING A SCHOOL ADDITIONAL
TIME FOR ACCREDITATION AND IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ARE ACCURATE
WHEN WE MAKE THESE
CALCULATIONS. I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT FOR ME AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO GOALS BEYOND
PROVIDING A FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOL ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
MEDITATION. THE GREATER POLICY
ISSUES THE CHRONIC SHORTAGE AND
MEL DISTRIBUTION OF DENTISTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA HAS PUT A HANDFUL OF
DENTAL SCHOOLS. HAS A HANDFUL
OF THAT THE SCHOOLS ANOTHER
THOUSANDS OF FLY ONLY A SELECT
FEW ART ADMITTED. BY WAY OF
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY TWENTY. THE
USC DENTAL SCHOOL HAD TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
APPLICANTS AND ONLY A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR WERE ADMITTED.
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
DENTAL SCHOOL HAD ONE THOUSAND
A HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
APPLICANTS. AND ONLY EIGHTY
WERE ADMITTED. SIMILARLY LOMA
LINDA WHICH IS CLOSER TO OUR
DISTRICT. I HAD ONE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
APPLICANTS AND ONLY A HUNDRED.
OR ADMITTED THE STATISTICS
PAINT A BLEAK PICTURE AS WE
STRUGGLE TO REMEDY THE
PERSISTENT PERVASIVE PROBLEM OF
NOT HAVING ENOUGH DENTISTS IN
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE. AND
PARTICULARLY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ONE THAT I
REPRESENT. THIS BRINGS TO ME
SECOND POINT THE MALICE
PROVISION OF DENTISTS. THE
SCHOOLS I MENTION ARE QUITE
EXPENSIVE. AND IT IS NOT
UNUSUAL FOR GRADUATING DENTISTS
TO HAVE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PLUS. LOAN DEBT. IN LAWNDALE
THIS HEAVY LOAN BURDEN CREATES
AN INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
GRAVITATE TO PRACTICE IN AREAS
WHERE THEY WILL MAXIMIZE OUR
INCOME. DOES DO NOT EXPECT TOO
MANY TO PRACTICE IN POOR
COMMUNITIES. OUR RESEARCH ALL
THE FOR EXAMPLE THAT IMPERIAL
COUNTY MY DISTRICT THE RATIO OF
DENTIST. TO POPULATION HAS ONE
FOR EVERY FOUR THOUSAND.
CONTRAST TO THIS RATIO IN MARIN
COUNTY ONE TO EIGHT HUNDRED. IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT ARE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB ELEVEN
SIXTEEN TO REMEDY THIS PROBLEM
BY AUTHORIZING THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL BOARD. TO EVALUATE AND A
QUALIFIED APPROVED FOR DENTAL
SCHOOLS YEAH JEFF OBJECTIVE WAS
TO CREATE ADDITIONAL. SOURCE OF
DENTAL PROVIDERS. WHO WOULD
HAVE TO PASS THE REQUIRED EXAMS
AND WE'RE REQUIRED TO PRACTICE
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA. THE RESULT
OF THIS LEGISLATION WITH THE
ACCREDITATION OF TWO FOREIGN
DENTAL SCHOOLS LA SALLE
UNIVERSITY IN GONE ONE OF WATER
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR. AND THE
MODEL WITH DENTAL SCHOOL IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THE SALAD UP
TO ITS PURPOSE AND HIS GRADUATE
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
STUDENTS. WHO HAVE PASSED
REQUIRED EXAMS AND MANY ARE
PRACTICING IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. EITHER ON THEIR
OWN OR THROUGH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE AUTOMATED
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES. WILL
DOUBLE WILL GRADUATE ITS FIRST
CLASS THIS YEAR AND IT IS
EXPECTED THAT THEY WILL PASS
THEIR EXAMS AND OF COURSE.
PROVIDED DENTAL CARE TO
CALIFORNIA'S AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. SO JUST LIKE
LEGISLATORS BEFORE US HAD THE
FORESIGHT TO CREATE THIS
PROGRAM I FIRMLY BELIEVE. THAT
IT IS OUR DUTY TO ENSURE THAT
IT CONTINUES- THE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR DEADLINE IS
SIMPLY NOT ACHIEVABLE. AND
WITHOUT AN EXTENSION MOBILE
LOSE ITS GRADUATION AND
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY-
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WILL
SUFFER AND THOSE STUDENTS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY THERE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN THIS CHAIR FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TO GIVE US AN
EXTENSION TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME AND
THAT ARE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS-
IN PERSON. AND WILL BEGIN THEN
WITH- MISTER RICHARD POLANCO
AND IF YOU COULD KINDLY LIMITER
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHATEVER RIGHT MISER
CHAIRMAN VICE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M RICHARD
POLANCO FORMER MEMBER OF THIS
DISTINGUISHED BODY I HAD THE
HONOR. OF SERVING SIXTEEN YEARS
EIGHT. YEARS HERE EIGHT IN THE
SENATE THE LAST FOUR YEARS AS
OF SENATE MAJORITY LEADER I WAS
HERE IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
WHEN CRAIG KEY. VERY VERY
EFFECTIVE TRUSTWORTHY. OF
MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
INTRODUCED THIS BILL AND THE
BILL WAS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF FOREIGN TRAINED DENTISTS.
AND TO ESTABLISH A PROCESS THAT
CAN BE UTILIZED BY FOREIGN
DENTAL SCHOOLS THAT MEET. AND
ARE YOU CLEVELAND TO THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL SCHOOL
SANDERS STANDARDS EXCUSE ME.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT IS VERY
SIMPLE IT IS ASKING FOR AN
EXTENSION. IT TAKES EIGHT TO
TWELVE YEARS. TO IMPLEMENT AND
MOVE FORWARD. TO COMPLETION
UNDER THE CODE A PROCESS THE
ANALYSIS IS INCORRECT WHEN IT
SAYS THAT PRIOR TO. FIFTEEN ARE
TWENTY FIFTEEN COATED DID NOT
OFFER AN ACCREDITATION PROCESS
FOR DENTAL SCHOOLS LOCATED
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOUR OFFICES WERE PROVIDED WITH
THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT. CALLED
COTA SUPPLEMENTAL TO IT READS
ON JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
ON INTERNATIONAL ACCREDITATION
BEGAN TO ACCEPT ADDITIONAL
APPLICATIONS REFER TO AS THE P.
A. C. V. SURVEYS. THOSE SURVEYS
IN THAT PARTICULAR STRUCTURE IS
ON PAGE FOUR. MEMBERS OF WHAT.
IS SO DISTURBING ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR MEASURE IS THAT IF
THIS WAS CORPORATE AMERICA
ASKING FOR AN EXTENSION. IT
WOULD BE GRANTED. THE ISSUE IN
THE AND NOW MAY REFERENCE TO A
FLYER. A FLYER THAT WAS POSTED
AND A FLYER THAT WAS UTILIZED
BY MODEL UNIVERSITY MOLDOVA USA
A LICENSE CALIFORNIA- A COMPANY
THAT PROVIDES. RECRUITMENT AND
MARKETING SERVICES ALL THAT
FLYER DID WAS REPLICATE THE
GENERAL REQUIREMENTS THAT EXIST
THAT WERE SUBMITTED. IN THE
ADMISSIONS DURING THE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS THIS IS A
BILL MEMBERS THAT RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
ONLY FOUR NO VOTES THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL WAS ALSO SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA EXCUSE ME THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
TEN MINUTES ARE UP THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL PRIMARY
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR ON
THE LINE OPERATOR IS THERE ANY
OTHER ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
YEAH I'M I'M UNDERLYING
EARNINGS REPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT HOLIDAY PLEASE COME.
YES. IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE
MEETINGS I'VE BEEN PRACTICING A
PRACTICING DENTIST IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY THREE I'M A GRADUATE OF
THE **** OUT THERE ONE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON ABOUT THE
MEXICO- I. 240-280-1550 TWO
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE A
DENTIST SHORTAGE. THE STUDY
CONDUCT IF YOU GO AGO BY. HAYES
PHD A PROFESSOR OF FROM UCLA.
CALIFORNIA HAVE A SHORTAGE OR
HOUSING SHORTAGE OF AT LEAST
TEN THOUSAND MEDICAL DENTAL
PROFESSIONALS. IN THE
UNDERSERVED AREA ANY PARTICULAR
DAY LOOKING OPEN AREA. I SERVE
ON THE DENTAL BOARD'S. I WAS
APPOINTED TWICE BY GOVERNOR
BROWN THEREFORE I AM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE DENTAL BOARD
PROCESS OF A CREDIT IMPORTANT
DENTAL SCHOOL. MIDDLEMORE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR FOLLOW THE
COR GUIDELINES OF ACCREDITATION
OF CODA. IT'S APPROVAL PROCESS
TO GO MORE THAN TWO OR THREE
YEARS THAT THE DENTAL BOARD
PROCESS. BUT THEY PUT A GREAT
PICTURE PROSOPIS ONLINE LONGER
THAN THAT HE TOOK THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAUDI ARABIA THAT
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILL DEAL TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO GET
APPROVED THAT'S TWELVE YEARS.
THE RECENT ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS IS THAT ONCE A
DEFICIENCY WAS FOUND. BY THE
DENTAL BOARD THIS COOL HAD ONLY
HAD. A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS
IN WHICH TO FIX THE ISSUE AND
REAPPLY FOR APPROVAL ONCE
AGAIN. UNDER THE KONA STANDARD
WANTED EFFICIENCIES FOLLOW BY
THE ON SITE TEAM THE DENTAL
SCHOOL NEXT TO WAIT THREE YEARS
BEFORE YOU CAN REAPPLY. AGAIN
FOR APPROVAL- I'VE ONCE AGAIN-
I CAN ATTEST TO THAT THE BRAIN
IN A POINT DENTAL SCHOOL. TWO
OF MY CHILDREN GRADUATED FROM.
AND I'M PRACTICING IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THEY ARE HARD
HIGHLY REGARDED BY THEIR
PATIENTS. SO PLEASE- I ASK FOR
YOUR APPROVAL. ON UP BOTH. A
AYE AYE VOTE ON THE IS VERY
IMPORTANT AB. FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT CAN. THE TO
TRY WHEN THIS. IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LAW FOR ANY.
MAY OF THE SIM WISHING INDICATE
SUPPORT. WITH NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE A PART OF AB. FIFTEEN FIFTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. IF YOU ARE IN A SUPPORT
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE UP TO
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THE
BOOKSTORES CALIFORNIA I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE DAM. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WILL NOW OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME WE. HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL SO. PLEASE LEAVE YOUR
COMMENTS TO MORE THAN MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING THIS CHAIRMAN OF
THE CAN. SAID CORP WITH THE K.
DENTAL SO. REPRESENTING MORE
THAN TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DENNIS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE DENTAL BOARD
SUNSET REVIEW BILL AB FIFTEEN
NINETEEN AUTHORED BY THE CHAIR.
INCLUDED A PROVISION THAT
SHIFTED THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
APPROVING FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOLS FROM THE DENTAL BOARD
TO THE COMMISSION ON DENTAL
ACCREDITATION. THE LANGUAGE IN
FIFTEEN NINETEEN WAS NOT ONLY A
REFLECTION OF CONCERNS RAISED
DURING PASSED ON THE BOARD
SUNSET REVIEWS. BUT ALSO
ILLUSTRATED A GROWING SHIFT A
FOREIGN SCHOOL APPROVAL. IN
SIMILAR FASHION THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S TWENTY SEVENTEEN SUNSET
BILL SHIFTED THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO APPROVE
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL SCHOOLS
TO OUTSIDE ENTITIES. CUTTERS
APPROVAL PROCESS IS A WORKABLE
PATHWAY TO ACCREDITATION USING
THE DENTAL PROFESSIONS MOST UP
TO DATE AND EVER EVOLVING
STANDARDS. FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOL APPROVAL IS SOMETHING
THAT THE DENTAL BOARD SIMPLY
DOES NOT HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO
DO CONFIDENTLY. BY SHIFTING THE
APPROVAL PROCESS THE CODA BORN
DENTAL SCHOOLS WILL BE HELD TO
THE SAME STANDARDS AT ALL
DENTAL SCHOOLS IN THE UNITED
STATES. CODE OVERSIGHT FOR
FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOLS IS NOT
ONLY MORE EFFICIENT BUT A
SUPERIOR METHOD TO FULL BOARD
APPROVAL. BECAUSE GRADUATES
WILL BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
LICENSURE IN ALL FIFTY STATES
AND THEREFORE PRACTICE ANYWHERE
IN THE COUNTRY. FOR THESE
REASONS CD RESPECTFULLY POSES
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE IN HERE UP HERE IN
OPPOSITION. AND ONE MOMENT WORK
WE HAVE ONE CUED UP WE JUST GOT
TO KEEP IT UP WE JUST GOT TO
GET THERE MY NUMBERS AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB. FIFTEEN
FIFTY TWO. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THE OPPOSITION OF AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTY. MMHM. OKAY. AND
WE'LL TRY TO GO TO LINE TWO
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWO FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
WE'LL GO ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
THIS IS OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO- AND WHAT
CITY. LOOKS LIKE NOBODY IS
RESPONDING TO THE ONLINE SO
WE'LL JUST MOVE ON TO- NO MORE
IN Q. IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEE NOAM ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHICH HAS BEGIN
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME.WILL
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS WE CAN WITH
A SIMILAR CHEN FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. OF
THANK YOU RESEARCHER
APPRECIATE- THE INTELLIGENCE.
NO AS A STANDARD MEDINA
RESEARCH ON THE BILL. THE BILL
CHANGE THE PREVIOUS AGREED UPON
TIMELINE AND HOPES TO IMPROVE
THE OVERALL ACCREDITATION
PROCESS. HELPS PROVIDE FOR
DENTAL SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH
MORE GRADUATION OPPORTUNITIES.
AND EVERY TIME I TALK TO CDA
WHEN THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TO DISCUSS. IS TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE. AND WHICH STUDENTS CAN
GOING TO THE DENTAL INDUSTRY.
YET I SEE. THIS IS INTENT OF
THE BILL BUT THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IS IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS. THAT MAKES
ME THINK. THAT PERHAPS THE
INTENT THE RESULTS OF THE BILL
COULD BE DIFFERENT. SO MY
QUESTION. TO THE AUTHOR IT. IS
WHY DO YOU THINK. THE CDA IN
OPPOSITION AND HAVE YOU TRIED
TO WORK WITH THE CDA. IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO. COME TO A
AGREEMENT. IT SO MUCH HERE. SO
TOUCH ON IT AND ALL ASK ONE OF
THE WITH TO ALLOW BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATIONS WITH- SEVERAL
NEW BOARD MEMBERS- OF THE CD
EIGHT OR I'M SORRY OF THE-
DENTAL BOARD ASSOCIATION WHO
HAS SHED LIGHT ON. SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCE HERE I HEARD THE
OPPOSITION LOUD AND CLEAR AND I
DON'T THINK WE DISAGREE WITH.
THE STANDARD THAT'S BEEN SET BY
UTILIZING THE QUOTA PROCESS IN
FACT THAT WE'RE SAYING THAT WE
ARE ADHERING TO THAT PROCESS
GIVEN THE HIGHER STANDARDS THAT
ARE BEING SET. AS IT RELATES TO
THE DENTAL ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE
FOR- MIGHT. EITHER ONE OF THE
TWO WITNESSES TO KIND OF
ELABORATE ON THAT I'VE NOT HAD
ANY DIRECT CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CDA SPECIFICALLY TO THIS
BUT I THINK YOUR POINT IS WELL
INTENT ON TRYING TO EXPAND- THE
DENTAL- PROFESSIONAL. AREA TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT IS
THE ULTIMATE GOAL- THAT WE ALL
HAVE- SPECIFICALLY WITH THIS
BILL AND THE APPEAL THAT THE
SCHOOLS HAVE FOR STUDENTS. TO
ATTEND AND ULTIMATELY COME BACK
TO CALIFORNIANS ARE BUT A
MASSIVE CLASS OF ONE OF THE TWO
WITNESSES CAN OPERATE ON DELUDE
DENTAL SOLICITATION. LAST
SUMMER CHEN TO WHICH. THE
PRIMARY WITNESS TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION. MR LOW APPS DON'T BE
GREAT OF RELIEF FOR- DURING.
OKAY M. POLANCO DO WISH TO HAVE
THE QUESTION REPEATED OR GPS
WOULD YOU PLEASE RESTATE THE
QUESTION. ABSOLUTELY THIS BLOG
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
SO AS I SAID THE INTENT IS TO
HAVE A MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FORMED- THE GRADUATE STUDENTS
IN THE DENTAL INDUSTRY TO BE
ABLE TO PRACTICE IN INDUSTRY
AND ONE OF THE MAIN. TENANTS OF
THE CD AS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A PIPELINE FOR
STUDENTS TO COME INTO THE
DENTAL INDUSTRY AND I SEE THAT
IS THE INTENT OF THE BILL YET
THE CDA IS IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS SO IT SEEMS THE INTENT OF
THE BILL THE RESULTS OF. WHAT
WE WANT COULD BE- FROM OPPOSITE
IDEOLOGIES SO IF YOU CAN EXPAND
ON THAT WHY DO YOU THINK CD'S
OPPOSITION AND I'M ALSO ASKING
HAVE THEIR DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU
AND THE CDA. AND I ALSO HUMBLY
ASK THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL-
SINCE HE HAS NOT YET SPOKEN TO
THE CDA TO SOUNDS LIKE TO IF
THERE IS- WITH THE IN DOLCE- IN
TERMS OF FUTURE DISCUSSIONS. TO
DISCUSS WITH. CDA SINCE THE
IMPACT THEM THE MOST. YES UP.
SEVERAL QUESTIONS THERE FIRST
ARC WE BEEN IN. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL BOARD. YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL BOARD HAS NOT TAKEN A
POSITION. ON THE BILL. UP WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATION WITH. AND I'M
ASSUMING BASED ON THE ANALYSIS
THAT- THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
ARE IN CONVERSATION. AND AS A
RESULT YOU HAVE WHAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU IN THE ANALYSIS.
WITH REGARDS TO THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION AS I
MENTIONED. THEY WERE THE
SPONSORS ORIGINALLY. OF A BILL
THAT WAS GOING TO ADDRESS. THE
NEED TO HAVE MORE DENTISTS WE
HAVE SIX DENTAL SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. IF EACH ONE IS
GRADUATING EVERY YEAR ONLY A
HUNDRED. RIGHT THAT'S A VERY
SMALL NUMBER WE ARE BEYOND
WANTING TO CHANGE THE POLICY
THE POLICY WAS CHANGED LAST
YEAR. ON THE INSISTENCE OF THE
OMNIBUS BILL OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHICH WAS. NO LONGER CALIFORNIA
DENTAL BOARD WILL YOU BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ACCREDITING.
FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOLS WE ARE
HERE TODAY TO SAY WE NEED. A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. TO DO
THE ACCREDITATION WE I
GRADUATED OVER TWO HUNDRED FROM
MEXICO WHO ARE PRACTICING IN
MANY COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE PASSED THE TEST SO IT'S
NOT A QUESTION OF COMPETENCY
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF NOT
HAVING AN EQUIVALENT STANDARD.
WE HAVE BEFORE YOU A NEED TO
EXTEND THE TIME TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS I HOPE I ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION. AND I WANT TO JUST
COMMIT TO THE- MEMBER LAST A
QUESTION THAT WE WILL DIRECTLY
SIT DOWN. WITH THE DENTAL
ASSOCIATION AND SEE EXACTLY
WHERE- THE DIFFERENCES ARE WHAT
I HEARD HERE IN THEIR
OPPOSITION AS THE- ASSUMPTION
THAT THERE IS A DESIRE BY
FOREIGN SCHOOLS TO NOT. COMPLY
BY THE CODE A PROCESS AND THAT
IS NOT THE CASE WE'RE NOT
ARGUING OR DEBATING THAT POLICY
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS WE NEED
MORE TIME BECAUSE THE COURT
PROCESS IS GOING TO TAKE A LOT
LONGER THAN THE DENTAL BOARD
PROCESS TECH. AND THE EXAMPLE
IS THE SAUDI ARABIA SCHOOL-
THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE OF
PERSPECTIVE BASED ON ANALYSIS
RIGHT UP THAT IT TOOK FAR
LONGER THAN WHAT THE ANALYSIS I.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I MAY ADD
ONE MORE. TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION ON THE NEED. IN THE
LETTER THAT YOU RECEIVED FROM
THE DENTAL ASSOCIATION. AND THE
TESTIMONY YOU HEARD. EVERY
GRADUATE. FROM A FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOL THAT GETS A CREDIT FROM
THE ACCREDITED IF THEY COME
FROM CALIFORNIA THEY CAN
PRACTICE ANYWHERE IN THE UNITED
STATES. THE BILL. THAT KEELEY
HAD REQUIRED EVERY STUDENT FROM
CALIFORNIA WHO WENT TO EITHER.
MOLDOVA OR MEXICO UPON
GRADUATION THEY CAN ONLY
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
LICENSE IS IT AND WHY IS THAT
IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE 2225% OF CALIFORNIA
DENTAL SCHOOL GRADUATES WHO GET
LICENSED. LEAVE CALIFORNIA TO
PRACTICE. SO THE GAP. TO
CLOSING THE SHORTAGE OF
DENTISTS IN LOW INCOME RURAL
AND URBAN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY DO NOT EXIST. IT'S GOING
TO CONTINUE. ALL WE ARE ASKING
IS GIVE US MORE TIME TO
COMPLETE THE CODE A PROCESS.
NEXT YEAR THE FIRST SEVEN
STUDENTS CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
WILL GRADUATE FROM MOLDOVA. WE
HAVE ALREADY GRADUATED OVER TWO
HUNDRED FROM MEXICO. AGAIN IT'S
THE TIME ISSUE MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT WE ARE ASKING FOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THOSE ANSWERS
AND I HAVE NOTHING BUT THE
UTMOST RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL- HIS POLICY HAS
ALWAYS BEEN SOMETHING IN WHICH
I REALLY APPRECIATE IN TERMS OF
RESEARCH. IN PARTICULAR FOR
THIS PARTICULAR CALL YOU STATED
MORE TIME AND I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT BASED ON WHAT I'VE
STUDIED AND BASED ON WHAT I'VE
LOOKED AT THE MORE TIME WICKS
TO EIGHT. TO TEN YEARS EIGHT TO
TEN YEARS FOR THIS PROCESS TO
TAKE COMPLAINTS FROM START TO
FINISH. BASED ON WHAT I'VE SEEN
THE DATA EIGHT TO TEN YEARS
SEEMS QUITE LONG FOR WHAT NEEDS
O BE ACCOMPLISHED SO. THAT IS
MY CONCERN THAT EIGHT TO TEN
YEARS OR SOMETHING WHICH WE
HOPE TO SEE STUDENTS GOING TO
WITH THE DENTAL INDUSTRY AT A
FASTER EXPEDITIOUS PACE ADDED
TWO YEARS FOR ME PERSONALLY
THIS IS A BIT TOO LONG I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THE AUTHOR AND THE
TESTIMONY- BUT BASED ON. THOSE
THINGS I'VE SEEN I
UNFORTUNATELY CANNOT SUPPORT
THE BILL AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR REFRESH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS A MERCHANT WILL GO ON INTO
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER MEDINA THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. NO I TO- CD
INTENT OF THE BILL. AND
CERTAINLY- I'M HAPPY TO SEE-
MORE DENNIS- THAT ARE NEEDED.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS. TO THE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. JUST TO TRY
TO CLARIFY. WHAT THE SITUATION.
IS THAT NOW EXIST IF I MIGHT.
SO TO THE WITNESS MR POLANCO-
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT UNIVERSITIES HERE
RIGHT THE NEW JERSEY THAT THEY
LAST SATURDAY AND MOLDOVA- ONE
OF THEM IS ALREADY ACCREDITED.
IS THAT YES ONE ONE WAS A
CREDIT ONE IS ACCREDITED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LET ME STATE THIS
WITH. TO HAVE BEEN ACCREDITED
BY THE DENTAL BOARD ONE IN
MEXICO ONE IN MOTHER OVER. THE.
DENTAL SCHOOL IN MEXICO APPLIED
FOR THE QUOTA PROCESS IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THEY WERE DENIED
THERE'S A LETTER TO THAT
EFFECT. AND SO YOUR YOUR
QUESTION IS THERE'S REALLY AT
THIS POINT IN TIME OF THE-
MOLDOVA IS THE UNIVERSITY IS
THE DENTAL SCHOOL THAT IS STILL
UNDER THE- CALIFORNIA DENTAL
BOARD OF JURISDICTION UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND THEN IT
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IT WOULD
COME UNDER THE CODE OF THAT
THAT BY THEN IT WAS COME UNDER
QUOTA AND UNDER THE KOTA
GUIDELINES AND THEIR OWN TIME
TABLE MEMBERS IT IS VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE. AND IF THE INTENT
IS TO DO AWAY WITH WITH. THE
ACCREDITATION OF THIS
PARTICULAR- CAN THE DE. SCHOOL
THE NEW BE FRONT ABOUT IT AND
JUST THAT BUT IF IT NOT. THEN
IT IS MOVE THE BILL. THIS IS
WORK TO SEE IF THEY CAN BE
BETTER THEN WE A COMMON AND
ASSURE. THAT THE OP. FOR A-
QUALIFIED EDUCATION. IN
DENTISTRY. CAN BE CAN CONTINUE
TO BE OFFERED. AND DO I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY THAT THE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS IS TAKING
UP TO I WROTE DOWN ELEVEN YEARS.
THE ANSWER IS CORRECT YES AND
THE INITIAL PROCESS IN COURT IT
STARTED. PURSUANT TO THEIR OWN
REPORT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN. IT WAS NOT UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT THE
FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOL IN SAUDI
ARABIA. WAS APPROVED. AND THE-
SCHOOL IN MEXICO WHO ALSO
APPLIED IN THE PROCESS PURSUANT
TO THAT REPORT THAT YOUR STAFF
HAVE. AND THEY WERE DENIED. BUT
LATER PROVED THE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT STATUS IS THE COULD
HAVE APPEALED IT. WE'RE NOT
SURE WE KNOW THAT THEY HAD SENT
A LETTER- OF WHICH- I BELIEVE
THIS YOUR STAFF SHOULD HAVE AND
BASICALLY FROM THEIR ATTORNEY-
QUOTA. MARC SUMMERS A LAW FIRM
INDICATING THAT THEY WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT AFTER ALL
THIS TIME AND RESOURCES THAT
THEY WOULD NOT BE ACCREDITED.
AND WHAT UNIVERSITY ARE YOU
REFERRING TO. THEY LESS AREA IN
ONE ABOUT THE MEDICAL. A. N. N.
N. HOW WHAT WOULD YOU TELL ME
WHAT WHY IS THE REASON FOR SUCH
A LONG PROCESS IN OUR TRADITION
HERE OF COLLEGES IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE SCHOOLS
YOU KNOW IS DONE RATHER QUICKLY
SO WHY AND WHY IN THIS PROCESS
DOES IT TAKE SO LONG. THAT WAS
A VERY FUNDAMENTAL POLICY
QUESTION IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. THERE'S ONLY BEEN ONE
SCHOOL THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. THAT
THE COURT HAS APPROVED FOR
DENTAL SCHOOL. OF YOUR QUESTION
IS A QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
MEDINA- THAT IS- IT'S LIKE WHY
DOES IT TAKE SO LONG. THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL BOARD THAT
ESTABLISHED THE REGULATIONS-
DIDN'T TAKE ELEVEN YEARS. AND
THOSE STANDARDS AS THE LETTER
FROM THE- DENTAL ASSOCIATION-
THE DENTAL BOARD WAS IN
COMMUNICATION AND CO TO
STANDARDS- WE MAKE SURE THAT
THE EDUCATION STANDARDS ALL
SEVEN OF THEM COMPETENCY.
FACILITIES. ADMISSIONS ALL.
SEVEN FOUR TO FIVE. INCH
BINDERS WITH INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
OF DATA NOW THIS IS ALL DONE AT
NO EXPENSE. TO THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS. THE APPLICANT. IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL COSTS. IT
SHOULD NOT TAKE ELEVEN YEARS IT
BEGS THE QUESTION. THEN WHY.
WHEN WE KNOW WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF DENTISTS. YEAH I. VERY MUCH
UNDERSTAND THAT- CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WHO PROBABLY HAVE
GOTTEN TURNED DOWN FROM SCHOOLS
OF DENTISTRY- WITHIN CALIFORNIA
IF THEY'RE LIMITED OF WANTING
TO GO ESPECIALLY TO ACCREDITED
SCHOOLS OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY-
I MYSELF SIDE AMERICAN STUDENTS
GOING TO MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN
SPAIN WHEN THEY WERE TURNED
AWAY FROM MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN
UNITED STATES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
C. NONE AS A MEMBER PRESS IF
YOU WISH TO CLOSE. I DO THINK
YOU SO MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR FOR.
LÏNG JUST SAID DELIBERATION
DEBATE. TO TAKE PLACE BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE
SHED LIGHT ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES- REGARDING-
THE SHORTAGES. THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
PROFESSIONAL DENTISTS- THE ONE
IS THE PROCESS. THAT TAKES SUCH
A LONG TIME WITH CODA- AND THE
SHIFT THAT WE MADE. THE TO THE
DENTAL BOARD- DESIRE TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MAKE AND POLICY
THAT WAS APPROVED. RECENTLY BUT
THE QUESTION ALSO. ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT. FOREIGN SCHOOLS
WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO STAY.
IN PLACE. TO PROVIDE THOSE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AT
LOWER COST. WITH THE CONDITIONS
OF THEM COMING BACK TO SERVE
IN. UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE. YOU
KNOW THOSE NUMBERS IMPERIAL
COUNTY RACIAL DENTIST
POPULATION ONE. EVERY FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED. IN
CONTRAST TO THE RACIAL. OF
DENTISTS IN MARIN COUNTY. WHICH
IS ONE- AND EVERY HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO- MEMBERS OF THEIR
POPULATIONS WE HAVE A- SERIOUS-
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST. IN SOME
ARE MORE POOR COMMUNITIES AND
SOME OR ALL ARE MORE AFFLUENT
COMMUNITIES. AND SO WHAT WE'RE
ASKING HERE IS AN EXTENSION OF
TIME. AND PERHAPS. TWENTY
THIRTY SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME
IS ONE OF THE COLLEAGUES AS
MENTIONED BUT THAT'S BASED ON
THE RESEARCH IT'S DONE. THAT IT
WILL TAKE ORDER TO APPROVE THIS
PROCESS- IF THERE IS A
DIFFERENT DATE. THAT OTHER
MEMBERS WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE SCHOOL TO
PROCEED. AND MEET SOME OF THE
BENCHMARKS AS ONE OF THE
WITNESSES AS JUST ARTICULATED.
WOULD BE HAPPY AND OPEN TO
CONSIDERING THAT AND WE WILL
MEET DIRECTLY AS I'VE BEEN
TOLD- OUR TEAM AND THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL HAD MET WITH THE-
DENTAL ASSOCIATION TO GET AT
THE CORE OF THEIR OPPOSITION
WHICH WHAT I HEARD WAS. OF
THEIR ADAMANT ABOUT THE CODA
PROCESS AND WE DON'T DISAGREE.
AT WE'RE JUST SAYING WE NEED A
BIT MORE TIME TO MEET THAT
STANDARD OR THAT EXPECTATION OF.
TIME FRAME WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK- FOR YOUR VOTE.
AND- YOUR COULD. MISTER CHAIR
FOR A- REASONABLE- AND MODEST
THAT EXTENSION THAT WOULD HELP
THE STUDENTS CONTINUE WITH
THEIR EDUCATION COMPACT
CALIFORNIA AND SERVE THE
UNDERSERVED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I SUMMER GARCIA
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'VE HAD TO BOTH IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND ALSO IN PERSON.
AS I MENTIONED TO YOU OVER THE
PHONE THAT UNFORTUNATELY
BELIEVE THAT YOU'VE BEEN SOLD A
BILL OF GOODS AND AS YOU KNOW
THIS WAS BROUGHT FORTH TO OUR
COMMITTEE ON THE DENTAL.
BOARD'S SUNSET HEARING OF IN
THE PREVIOUS YEARS AND WE'VE
HAD ROBUST CONVERSATIONS WE
ALSO HEARD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE DISAGREEMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND AS THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS HOW WE TAKE.
OUR PRIDE IN OUR WORK AND THE
STAFF SPEAKS FOR THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR. HIMSELF AND SO WITH THE
DILIGENCE AND THE HARD WORK PUT
IN THIS EFFORT WE SEE POLICY
DISAGREEMENT AT THIS PARTICULAR
TIME WHICH IS WHY IT
UNFORTUNATELY. HAS A NO
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE BUT I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AS WE CONTINUE TO
HELP ADDRESS MANY OF THESE
ISSUES MOVING FORWARD SO WITH
THAT- IS THERE A MOTION. K.
THAT IS OUR SECOND. SINGLE
SECOND AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A SUMMER GARCIA. THAT
WILL LEAVE THE- WILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AS WE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. WELL NOW
THEN MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN THIS IS BY A SUMMER
FONG THIS IS AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR I SUMMER FONG THIS DOES
ENJOY TO PASS RECOGNITION ON
BOTH SIDES THE OP. THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBERS I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AB FORTY
NINETY FOUR WILL ALLOW
REGISTERED NURSE WHO WAS IN
CHARGE OF BLOOD COLLECTION AT A
MOBILE BLOOD BANK TO BE
AVAILABLE BY VIDEO
TELECONFERENCE BLOOD DONATIONS
STATE COUNTLESS LIVES ACROSS
THE STATE AND NATION AND
ACCORDING TO THE BLOOD CENTERS
OF CALIFORNIA SOMEONE NEEDS A
BLOOD TRANSFUSION EVERY THREE
SECONDS. DONATED BLOOD PRODUCTS
ARE USED TO TREAT INJURIES AND
DISEASES RANGING FROM CANCER
HEART DISEASE ORGAN TRANSPLANTS
TO SEVERE DRAMATIC INJURIES IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT WE
RELY ON KINDNESS AND GENEROSITY
OF BLOOD DONORS TO HELP SAVE
SICK INFORMAL CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CARBON
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE
BLOOD COLLECTIONS SCARCER BUT
CURRENT REGULATIONS ALLOW FOR
DEVIATIONS FROM STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY LAST APRIL GOVERNOR
NEWSOM EVEN ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER ENCOURAGING HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES TO MAXIMIZE THE USE
OF TELEHEALTH SERVICES AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO CONTINUE
TO ADJUST THE PRACTICES YOU'RE
BOUND TO BE SUCCESSFUL DURING
THE PANDEMIC. BLOOD DONATIONS
HAVE BECOME EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY AS INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE FOR KOBE
CAN DONATE BLOOD WITH THEIR
ANTIBODIES TO HELP PEOPLE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY SECOND EVEN HELP
TO CONTINUE THE STUDY THE
VIRUS. AT THE END THE DAY THIS
BILL IS ABOUT EXPANDING ACCESS
TO NEEDED BLOOD SUPPLIES FOR
FLEXIBILITY SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE BLOOD AND
BLOOD PRODUCTS ARE STILL
COLLECTED SAFELY AND
RESPONSIBLY EITHER WITH A NURSE
ON SITE WERE AVAILABLE VIA
VIDEO TELECONFERENCING AND I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT
I UNDERSTAND OPPOSITION
CONCERNS FOR PATIENTS AND
HEALTH AND THAT IS WHY WE'VE
BEEN VERY ACCOMMODATING BY
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE-
MOBILE BLOOD DONATIONS ARE
CONDUCTED WITH APPROPRIATE
SAFETY MEASURES. I JUST
BASICALLY I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THE STAFF
BUT IT SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT
WE HAVE THE SPECIFIED TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR BLOOD DONOR-
BLOOD OF LOBOTOMIZED REQUIRED
MOBILE BLOOD DONATIONS TO BE
HELD IN AREAS RELIABLE INTERNET
CONNECTION. REQUIRED BLOOD
BANKS REPORT IS THE P. EIGHT ON
ALL DONOR ADVERSE RISK EVENTS
AND REQUIRES THE PH TO REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON DONOR
ADVERSE EVENTS AT THE END OF
THE SUNSET PERIOD AND THIS BILL
WOULD OF COURSE IMPLEMENT A
SENSE THAT PERIOD. AFTER FIVE
YEARS SO WE ARE CERTAINLY WE
WERE WITH THE OPPOSITE BUT WE
SUPPOSED TO KNOWLEDGE- THERE
CONCERN AND WE WANT. TO HAVE OF
BLOOD COLLECTION DONE AS SAFELY
AS POSSIBLE NUMBER DOING TODAY
BY SEAN MCNALLY THE PRESIDENCY
OF. THAT HOUSING COMMITTEE
PUBLIC. ANOTHER LORI KAMMER
ADVOCATE FOR HOUSING COMMITTEE
POPPING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF
THE OPERATOR COMING OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. AB YEAH GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WELCOME.
OKAY GOOD MORNING PART OF THE
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY PERSONALY.
AND I'VE VERY SPECIAL THANK YOU
TO SEVEN OF THE FALL MY NAME IS
SEAN MCNALLY I AM THE PRESIDENT
AND CEO HOW CAN COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANK IN BAKER SHOW CALIFORNIA
AND I'M TESTIFYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. BLOOD
BANKS AND BLOOD COLLECTION PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN SAVING LIVES
PARTICULARLY IN THIS CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT WITH THE CODE
NINETEEN ANOTHER PANDEMIC
IMPACTS. AS WELL AS POTENTIAL
WILDFIRE EMERGENCIES. HOSPITALS
AND CARE GIVERS MUST HAVE THE
NECESSARY PUT SUPPLY. OUR
POLICY ADOPTION IS TO MAINTAIN
NURSES ON SITE AT ALL TIMES
THAT ARE PERMANENT LOCATIONS
WITH SELLING SODA MOBILE SITES
CUT SIGNIFICANTLY INTO OUR
ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE BLOOD
COLLECTION AND THAT IS THAT'S
JUST THE SIMPLE FACT. WE HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO CONDUCT OUR
MOBILE SITE COLLECTIONS WITH
NURSES WHO ARE NOT PRESENT AT
THE MOBILE SITE BUT WHO ARE
ALWAYS. IN CONSTANT ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION. WE CAN MAXIMIZE
OUR BLOOD COLLECTION AND WE CAN
DO THIS WHILE PROVIDING FULL
FULLY FOR THE SAFETY OF THOSE
WHO DONATE BLOOD AT THE SITES.
WE MAINTAIN CPR TRAINED AND
CERTIFIED STAFF. TO ADMINISTER
RESUSCITATION AND OTHER GENERAL
FIRST AID AT ALL SITES. BLOOD
DONATION FACT ARE NOT MEDICAL
OFFICES WITH MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
OTHER THAN WHAT IS USED TO
COLLECT BLOOD. AND THE FACT IS
THAT CPR GENERAL FOR STATE COST
TO DO THE FULL EXTENT OF
MEDICAL INTERVENTION POSSIBLE.
WHEN AWAITING A RESPONSE TO A
NINE ONE ONE CALL ME THAT OF
THE BLOOD DONOR APPEARS. TO
HAVE A MEDICAL EMERGENCY. BUT
EVENTS GIVING RISE TO NINE ONE
ONE CALLS ARE EXTREMELY RARE
BLOOD DONATION SITES. IN FACT
THE RISK OF A MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCIDENT WHILE DRIVING TO WORK
FROM A BLOOD DONATION SITE IS
GREATER THAN THE RISK OF A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY ARISING. FROM
A BLOOD DONATION. THAT'S THE
GOVERNOR ISSUES EXECUTIVE ORDER
ALLOWING BLOOD DONATION WITHOUT
THE PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF A
NURSE THERE HAVE BEEN NO
SERIOUS INCIDENTS STATEWIDE.
AND THE PROCESS HAS WORKED VERY
WELL. IN FACT YEAR HOW SHOULD
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO INCREASE
OUR BLOOD COLLECTION COMMITMENT
TO THE PANDEMIC WITH SCHOOLS
AND BUSINESSES SHUT DOWN. ALL
WE'RE ASKING IS TO KEEP DOING
WHAT WE HAVE THAT THE REALLY
SUCCESSFUL WOULD HAVE BEEN A
FAIRLY SUCCESSFUL PRACTICE. WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SIMPLY SIGNIFYING THEIR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR
IN THE GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ONE OUT
OF ONE OF THE LINES FOR PRIMARY
WHEN HE'S IN OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WE HAVE
ONE WITNESS IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. YES GOOD MORNING.
HELLO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JENNIFER MANLEY
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR. WHICH WE BELIEVE
ADDRESSED THE HOUSE OF LETTING
DONORS. IT'S STILL END THE
REQUIREMENT OF BLOOD BANKS HAVE
A REGISTERED NURSE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT DURING MOBILE BLOOD
DRAWS AND INSTEAD ALLOW PARENTS
TO MONITOR THE PROCESS VIA
TELECONFERENCE. ONLY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED OPPONENTS
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH UP TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. A CONCERN
THE PATIENT HAVE COULD BE RISKS
BY THE CHANGE. ONE CONCERN
INCLUDES RESPECT ME EXACERBATED
IN RURAL AREAS WITH BUT LACKS
RELIABLE INTERNET OR PHONE
SERVICE. BUT LIKELY LONGER
TRAVEL TIME TO RECEIVE CARE IN
CASE OF AN EMERGENCY WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED THE BOTH THE FLAG
HE INTERNET AND TRAP CALLED
DURING TELECONFERENCING EVEN IN
URBAN AREAS. NEVER MIND A LACK
OF ACCESS TO RURAL AREAS AND IN
THIS SITUATION EXCEPT NEW
TRUTHS CAN BE EXTREMELY HARMFUL.
MEETING WITH PROPONENTS THEY
NEVER ARTICULATED NOR
DEMONSTRATED AND NEED FOR
REMOVING OUR CERVANTES. ONLY
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR EFFICIENCY
WHICH IS VERY CONCERNING TO US.
WHILE THE REST OF TRUCK WHAT
JOHN BLOOD OR NOT IF THE BEER
AT THE OTHER FORMS OF HEALTH
CARE THERE VERY WELL. THIS BILL
WOULD RELY ON THE BOTTOM IS WHO
DOES NOT HAVE THE TRAINING AND
KNOWLEDGE THAT EARNERS HAD.
IDENTIFIED AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
NEED FOR CARE AND WOULD
INCREASE THE ODDS THAT SUCH
THREATS COULD HAPPEN IF AGAIN
AFTER HEALTH EVENT. TWENTY
THREE MINS WE ASK FOR YOUR
NOBEL. EIGHTY FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SOME. ODD TO HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. ON THE
PHONE LINES AT A MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF ONE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TAYLOR JACKSON. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE UP TO
SIXTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN.
LINE SIXTY JULY IS OPEN. NEXT
CAROLINA A TWO SEVENTY
AIRLINES- OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS MET A ABOUT SCA CAL
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. IMAGE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER TO QUEUE AT
TIME. THANK YOU FOR MUCH BRING
IT BACK TO ME. DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTION FROM THE CAN. C. NINE
MR FONG WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK THIS CHAIR I JUST WANT
TO JUST SAY BLOOD DONATIONS CAN
BE DONE EFFECTIVELY AND SAFELY
EVEN IN MY SACK I MISS A GLOBAL
PEND. AND I APPLAUD THE WORK OF
BLOOD BANKS ACROSS THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO ADJUST THIS BILL
WILL PROMOTE. INCREASED ACCESS
THE BLOOD BANK SERVICES
STATEWIDE AND RURAL AREAS AND
IT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
IN PARTICULAR I UNDERSTAND THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS FOR
PATIENTS HEALTH AND THAT'S WHY
WE'VE BEEN AGAIN VERY
ACCOMMODATING BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
BLOOD MOBILE DONATIONS. ARE
CONDUCTED WITH APPROPRIATE
SAFETY MEASURES HOWEVER THERE
ARE ALSO MANY PATIENTS THAT ARE
HOSPITALS THAT ARE IN URGENT
NEED OF BLOOD FOR TRANSFUSIONS
AND TREATMENTS AND THAT'S A
NATIONAL SHORTAGE OF DONATED
BLOOD. WE ALL KNOW- INDIVIDUALS
IN OUR COMMUNITY IF AND IF
SOMEONE GETS IN A CAR WRECK A
NEEDS A BLOOD TRANSFUSION-
THOSE BLOOD SUPPLIES ARE VITAL
AND WE NEED TO BE EXPANDING
ACCESS. THROUGHOUT THE CITY
CALIFORNIA FOR THESE NEW
PRODUCTS AND SO WHAT WE'RE DRAW
WHAT WE DRAW CLOSER AT
THROUGHOUT THE ENDING AT THIS
BY. WE NEED TO BE A PREPARED TO
BLOOD PART READY TO ANY.
RESPECT AS WHEN I ABOUT. THANK
VERY MUCH MY RATHER MOST OF MY-
SO. BY THE MEMBER TO. NOW
SECTOR PLEASE CALL. AB FORTY
NINETY FOUR FONG PASS A AMENDED.
LOW FLORA HI FLORA I ARAMBULA.
BERMAN BURKE NIGHT BLOOM. CHEN
CHAN HI CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY
DELLY HI FONG FONG HI GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA I MULLIN. SALAS TAKING.
TEN I. ZERO NOTICE BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO
ADD ON ALL RIGHTNEXT UP YOUR
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY
NINE- RC TWO TO TWENTY NINE
HOLD. MR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
TWO NINE THE BILL THAT
PROHIBITS A PERSON REQUIRED TO
BE REGISTERED AS A SECURITY
GUARD FROM CARRYING OR USING A
FIRE ARM A BATON UNLESS
SECURITY GUARD. THE SECURITY
GUARD IS AN EMPLOYEE OF A
PRIVATE PATROL OPERATOR LYSONS
LICENSEE OR AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
STATE. MEMBERS AS THE COUNTRY
WHAT'S THE TRIAL OF THEIR
CHILDREN THE EX POLICE OFFICER
CHARGED WITH KILLING. OF GEORGE
FLOOR THERE WAS A SIMULTANEOUS
DISCUSSION REGARDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE TRAINING. OF
THE APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE.
THE CONVICTION OF THEIR
CHILDREN WAS THE FIRST UP IN
SECURING JUSTICE FOR GEORGE
PLOY. NOW THE NATION'S SETS ITS
SIGHTS ON THE OTHER THREE
OFFICERS THAT FAILED TO
INTERVENE AND ULTIMATELY
WATCHES WATCHES GEORGE FOR ITS
FINAL MOMENTS. ON EARTH EXPIRED.
BUT TODAY I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. AND BRING
AWARENESS TO THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT CARRY FIREARMS
BATONS. THEY ARE EMPLOYED TO
KEEP OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
PROPERTY SAFE AS WELL AS THE
FINANCIAL DEALINGS OF
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THEY ARE HARD TO KEEP
THE PEACE AT SPORTING EVENTS
AND CONCERTS. THEY ARE OUR
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS. WHILE
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS DIFFER
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT A NUMBER
OF AREAS I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THEY OFTEN FACE SIMILAR
SITUATIONS. EVEN TRAGIC ONES.
MEMBERS MARIO MATTHEWS WAS A
MEXICAN AMERICAN WHO WORKED AS
A WAREHOUSE WORKER. ACCORDING
TO A LAWSUIT FILED BY HIS
PARENTS ON JULY SECOND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AROUND THREE
THIRTY AM AFTER ATTENDING AN
OUTDOOR CONCERT FOLLOWING TWO
NBA EXHIBITION GAMES. MARIO
ENTERED THE GOLDEN ONE CENTER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THROUGH A
PROPPED OPEN DOOR WHICH WAS
PART OF THE MAIN ENTRANCE-
SURVEILLANCE SHOWED MARIO
RUNNING AROUND THE COURT AND
DRIBBLING AS IF HE WAS PLAYING
BASKETBALL. THEN TO UNIVERSAL
PROTECTION SECURITY PERSONNEL
BEGAN CHASING MARIO AND
EVENTUALLY DETAINED HIM. THE
LAWSUIT ALLEGES THAT MARIO WAS
TACKLED
DOWN N THE FLOOR. HIS HANDS
WERE HANDCUFFED BEHIND HIS BACK
AND THE TWO SECURITY PERSONNEL
GOTON TOP OF HIS BACK. ONE OF
THE SECURITY GUARDS USES RIGHT
NEED TO APPLY PRESSURE TO THE
SIDE AND MARIO SNACK FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOUR AND A HALF
MINUTES. IN ADDITION TO THE
INITIAL TO UNIVERSAL PROTECTION
SECURITY PERSONNEL. A THIRD
SECURITY OFFICER PLACED HIMSELF
ON MARIO'S BACK. MEMBERS THIS
SOUND FAMILIAR. MARIO BECAME
UNRESPONSIVE WAS TAKEN TO THE
HOSPITAL HE PASSED AWAY TWO
DAYS LATER. THE LAWSUIT CLAIMS
THAT THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
CORONER KNOWLEDGE THAT
RESTRAINTS WAS THE CAUSE OF
MORROW'S DEATH. ADDITIONALLY
THE CORONER'S PATHOLOGIST NOTED
DEEP BRUISING ON MORROW'S BACK
AS A RESULT OF THE WEIGHT AND
PRESSURE THAT HAD BEEN PLACED
ON HIM. MARIO WEIGHED A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE POUNDS. WELL
THE NATION DEBATES LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S TRAINING ON THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS
CURRENTLY HAVE NO TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR COURSES ON THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE. AB
TWO TWENTY NINE. WOULD ADD THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE TO THE
TRAINING COURSES WITHIN THE
PRIVATE SECURITY SERVICES ACT
INCLUDING TRAINING ON THE USE
OF OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE
FORCE. DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS AND
CULTURAL TRAINING. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
COURSE IN THE CARRYING AND USE
OF FIREARMS TO INCLUDE TRAINING
IN THE APPROPRIATE USE OF
FORCE. IT IS MY HOPE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION COULD HELP SAVE
OTHERS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND THE
BUREAU OF SECURITY AND
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES FOR
THEIR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH
THIS BILL. THOSE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR STUART
KATZ AN ATTORNEY FOR THE FAMILY
OF MORAL MATTHEWS AND DAVID
CHANDLER PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE SECURITY AGENCIES
GUARDS AND ASSOCIATES. MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN AND-
THE MODERATOR WE HAVE STIRRED
CATS ON THE PHONE WILL GO TO
MISTER KATZ FIRST. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MY NAME MISTER CAT
FAMILY ATTORNEY ONE OF THE
ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING THE
MATTHEWS FAMILY. I THINK THIS
LEGISLATION IS A VALUABLE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER.
THAT THERE ACTUALLY MORE
SECURITY CARDS IN CALIFORNIA.
THEN THERE ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. THERE IS A CONCERN
ABOUT OF INTERACTION BETWEEN.
SECURITY GUARDS IN THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AND WOULD FREQUENTLY
HAPPENS WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
GOT INVOLVED THE SITUATIONS. B.
UNFORTUNATELY. OF THE- MISS.
SITUATE BY THE C. GUARDS TENDS
TO AFFECT AN ADVERSE. THE
ACTIONS OF THE U. LATER
RESPONDING OFFICER- I THINK
PEOPLE HIGHER SECURITY HAVE
EXPECT THAT THEY DO HAVE THIS
TRAINING AND I SUSPECT THAT IF
YOU WERE TO ASK PEOPLE WHO ARE
HIRING SECURITY GUARDS AND
COMPANIES PROVIDING SECURITY
GUARDS- THEY WOULD BE UP SHE IF
THEY REALIZE THAT THIS LACK OF
TRAINING. I THINK THIS.
ASSEMBLY BILL IS A- THE STRONG
STEP IN THE RIGHT TO. AND CAN
ONLY HELP POTS- OUR FOR THE
PUBLIC IS WHOLE IS AS THOSE WHO
POINT SECURITY. THANK YOU THANK
VERY MUCH MR AND MR IF YOU'RE
ON THE PHONE LINE. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE HAVE YOU. THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING- MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS DAVID CHANDLER- PRESIDENT OF
CAL SAGA WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE SECURITY
AGENCIES GARCIA SOCIUS. OUR
MEMBERSHIP REPRESENTS OVER
CLOTHES HUNDRED OFF. SECURED
PROTECTION IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE- IN- WE
MR HOLD ON THIS. AND OF A
HUNDRED. IN GIVE SOME MORE. FOR
OUR SECURITY OFFICERS ANSWERED
PROFESSIONALS OUT IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITIES- THIS BILL WILL
MISS HOLDEN- SO. ELEGANTLY PUT
IT WILL ADD ESCALATION
ESCALATION OF FORCE WHEN AND
WHEN CULTURAL AWARENESS AND
OTHER ITEMS THAT WE ONLY TOUCH
AND BRIEFLY. IN IN THE SECURITY
TRAINING OF THOSE AUTHORIZED BY
THE REGULATION- CURRENTLY A
SECURITY OFFICER- GETS FORTY
HOURS OF TRAINING- VERSION LAW
ENFORCEMENT COULD BE A PORTIONS
MONTHS OF TRAINING. SO WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY WORKING WITH-
MISTER HOLES OFFICE. AND
CLOSING WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MOST MISTER CHANDLER ABOUT
MODERATORS ARE IN ELSE ON THE
PHONE I INTO THE- EVERY TO
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
AREN'T OF AB TWO NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN THE- ONE THEN
ZERO YOUR SIMPLE. OF AB. TWO
TWO NINE. AND ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. AND AGAIN IT'S
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO TWO NINE.
THEY DISCONNECTED YOU'LL HAVE
TO PUSH ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
ONE IN SUPPORT OF THE VIDEO
ROOM CONFERENCE ROOMS SEEN NINE
ANY SUPPORT THE CHAMBER. XENON
MADAM MODERATORS OR ANY BODY IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO TWO NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN. ZERO ONE HUNDRED
ZERO PURE IN OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF ONE OF
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MONICA GARCIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TWO TWO
NINE. AND WE HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AGAIN
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO SEVENTY
THREE RYAN SO MANY. THANK. BY
TWO SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE GAVE IT ABOUT WE
HAVE NO FURTHER. ALL RIGHT
THANK WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION TO Q. THANK YOU SO
MUCH BRING ABOUT THE COMMITTEE
ANYBODY THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. CNN MISTER HOLD
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST
APPRECIATE. THE NOTING AT THIS
POINT THE COLLABORATION THAT
HAS BEEN POINTED OUT BETWEEN
OUR OFFICE AND MR CHANDLER IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE SECURITY AGENCIES AND
GUARDS IT IS THAT KIND OF A
COLLABORATION I THINK HAS
PROVIDED A PRODUCT TO YOU
TODAY. THAT IS SOLID-
THOUGHTFUL AND QUITE FRANKLY
ADDRESSES ISSUES THAT I THINK
AS- TURNING CATID PRODUCT
POINTED OUT. THE PUBLIC AULIC
ALREADY BELIEVED WAS TAKING
PLACE SO- IT'S SENSIBLE IT'S-
APPROPRIATE TIME IN A PROVIDES
THE APPROPRIATE TRAINING-
THAT'S NECESSARY FOR THE
SECURITY GUARDS TO GO FORWARD
AND- SERVE THE PUBLIC. IN A
PROPER WAY AND IN A SAFE WAY.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
HOLD SAID. A- A SOME FROM THE
CHAIR CEMAT OF STATE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WE NEED A MOST A
SECTOR I'M SORRY. AND I CAN
SECOND. AB TWO TWO NINE HOLDEN
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
FLORA HI FLORA HI ARAMBULA.
BERMAN BLOOM BLOOM HI CHEN CHAN
HI CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY
HI FONG. GIPSON GIPSON I
GRAYSON. HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY. MCCARTY
MEDINA INA HI MULLIN. SALAS
SALAS. EIGHTEEN TEN I. ZERO
NOTICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL LEAVE THAT- CALL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
JUST TWO SEVENTY THREE IRWIN.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON MAKING THIS A BILL BETTER.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR THE LEGISLATURE HAS GONE
OUT OF ITS WAY TO ASSIST THE
LEGAL RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA
INDUSTRY WE'VE LOWERED THE
TAXES ON RECREATIONAL CANNABIS
WE'VE REDUCE THE REGULATORY
BURDEN. AND THIS YEAR WE WILL
BE ASKED YET AGAIN TO ASSIST
WITH LICENSURE AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE LEGAL
MARKET BUT I DO NOT THINK WE
NEED TO DO IT AT THE EXPENSE OF
OUR CHILDREN. AND THAT'S WHAT
AB TWO SEVENTY THREE IS ABOUT
THIS BILL LIMITS THE CONTENT
THAT MARIJUANA LICENSEES CAN
PLACE ON BILLBOARD'S. OPPONENTS
OF PROP SIXTY FOUR SOLD THEIR
INITIATIVE TO VOTERS WITH THE
PROMISE THAT THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
WOULD NOT TARGET OR ADVERTISED
TO CHILDREN. FIVE YEARS LATER
THE BILLBOARD ADVERTISING
MARIJUANA. INFUSED GUMMIES AND
HARD CANDIES WITH SHOPS NAMED
COOKIES COUNTING FLAVORS LIKE
LEMONADE. AND WITH SOME
ADVERTISEMENTS MIMICKING THE
LOGO OF SHOWS FEATURED ON
DISNEY. IT'S EASY TO SEE THAT
THE INDUSTRY HAS BROKEN THEIR
PROMISE AND IT'S TIME TO
PERFORM THE LOS. AB TWO SEVENTY
THREE PLACES REASONABLE
RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT CAN BE
ADVERTISED ON MARIJUANA
BILLBOARD SIMILAR TO
RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON
ADVERTISEMENTS IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON MEMBERS OF THE UN
AND I WILL ALSO ADD. THAT WE
HAVE TRIED TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY IS- IF THEY HAVE SOME
ISSUES ABOUT THE LIST OF ITEMS
THAT OF. THAT WE ARE- MAKE
INSURANCE USE BUT WE HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS UP UNTIL THIS
POINT SO- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO
BE A PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENTY
THREE. DR MARVIN SEPPALA THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF THE
HATED HAZELTON BETTY FORD
FOUNDATION AND THE NATIONAL
EXPERT ON ADDICTION TREATMENT
AND INTEGRATION OF EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES AND ALSO A
RUCHED JASON. SAROS ARE
REGISTERED DIETITIAN POLICY
RESEARCH ASSOCIATE AT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH- ASSOCIATED WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS IRWIN AND
BOTTOM UP- OPERATOR CAN WE OPEN
UP THE LINE FOR MARVIN. SHE'S
ON THE PHONE. HELLO I'M MORE
SURPLUS AND I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYWOMAN- FOR NOT
FORWARDING NOW THIS LEAD I AM
CAN ABOUT INFLUENCE THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY HAVE OF OUR
USE AND THE SUPPORT ANY LIMIT
AN EFFORT. CANNABIS IS SAFE FOR
MOST PEOPLE BUT RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT EARLIER ADOLESCENTS BEGIN
USING IT THE HIGHER THE
LIKELIHOOD OF PROTECTION AND WE
KNOW ADVERTISING. WORKS IN THE
ADVERTISED KNOW THE EARLIER GET
PEOPLE STARTED TO HIRE
LIKELIHOOD OF A LIFELONG.
ALCOHOL RESEARCH THAT TEND 15%
OF PEOPLE USE 90% OF THE
ALCOHOL. IF- IF THE PEOPLE
WITHOUT IS ALCOHOL USE
DISORDERS AND WE BELIEVE THE
SAME TO BE TRUE FOR CANNABIS
AND ALL OTHER DIRECTIONS
INCLUDING GAMBLING. SO NO STATE
HAS ADEQUATELY PROTECTED ARGUES
WHEN PASSING LEGISLATION TO
LEGALIZE- USE OF MARIJUANA. I
IMPLORE YOU TO PASS THIS
LEGISLATION AND COMMIT TO MORE
TO PROTECT OUR USERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR A SECOND WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. MISTER MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. YEAH
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS R. SURESH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE. ELECT
EXPRESSED MY SUPPORT FOR SOME
BILL TWO SEVENTY. I THINK
CANNABIS BUSINESSES ADVERTISING
BUILD THAT ARE VISIBLE AN INNER
OR STATE HIGHWAY WITHIN CAL.
WHAT HOLD THE PROMISE OF MADE
TO VOTE TO PASS. PROPOSITION
FIFTY FOUR. CALIFORNIANS WERE
TO THE WITHIN THE NEXT STRICKEN
SEARCH YOU PROTECT. INCLUDING
ADVERTISE RESTRICTS.
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE LETTER TO
CANNABIS. EXPOSING MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN TO ADD PROMOTING SUCH.
THAT IS KNOWN TO POSE TWENTY
BEEN IN THIS YEAR THAT YOUNG
EIGHT. HAS BEEN WILD. THAT YOU
TEXT OUT AB. OF CANNABIS
ALTHOUGH FORTY PRODUCTS
INCREASES YOUTH. IN YOUTH AND
PAS PERSON OF THE PRODUCTS WILL
BROADCAST AND DIGITAL. CAN
UTILIZE AUDIENCE COMPOSITION
DATA TO LIMIT ADVERTISED PLACE
IN MEDIA WERE YOU ARE LAW TO BE.
THERE'S NO RELEVANT. PROPER AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW ME DEVELOP
AFTER ADVERTISE WITHOUT RISKING
YOU FIXED. CHILDREN TEENAGERS
OR DRIVEN BY THE PARA ON A HIGH
WITH CAMPUS. WILL BE. WITH
ADVERTISING TO THE ALL AS TO
TRY THING PAT. IT IS
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT HIS
GRAYSON AT MIND HAVE BEEN X. AT
HIGHER RATES HELP ON BACK OF.
IN CAL. YOU THE MIND OR KEEN
ARE. GETS REPORT IF BY THE
LEGAL. OF A- ALCOHOL TOBACCO IN
CANADA TO. AS ALL THE LONG TERM
THE SPARE RESEARCH FROM.
CONSENT OF THE THAT. WE YOU TO
THE PROMISE MADE TO. VOTERS AND
SUPPORT A FAMILY TWO THREE IN
ORDER TO BETTER PROTECT OUR AND
MEDIC THE HELP. THAT THAT BY A
MARKETING. THANK YOU. ONE AND
THEN ZERO IN SUPPORT. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF THAT THE
REAL SICK YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
BATTLING COOPER FROM NIELSEN
MERGED BEHALF THE COUNTY
ACCOUNT COSTA IN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWO SEVENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE A FEW
LINES ONE MOMENT PLEASE. BOGART
SIDE OF THREE OH NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE ZERO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU HAVE A W. AND
WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT LINE OF
THE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MICHAEL SKIP ON
BEHALF OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE- WE
ARE FIRM SUPPORT IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
THREE AND WILL QUOTE THE LAST
LINE IN Q. OF. TWO EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU READY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO LINE WAITING FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER. WISHING
THIS BECAUSE SEEN NINE. WE HAVE
TO HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO SEVENTY THREE AND WE
WILL START WITH- BIGELOW. FOR
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE I
MAKE HIM A FIRST THINKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING. OUR
MEMBERS RANGE FROM SMALL FAMILY
OPERATION WITH A HAM OF THE TO
LARGE NATIONAL. COLLECTIVELY
ARE MEMBERS OPERATE OVER AND
PERCENT OF CAL LICENSED AVERAGE
THE. WHAT ARE WRITTEN
AMENDMENTS ARE COULD NOT RAMP
PARTIALLY RIGHT REMAIN A- TO AB.
SEVEN THREE. A CURRENT REMOVE
THE PO PROHIBITION ON BILLBOARD
OUT. AND ALSO AND ENTER HIGHWAY.
AND ADDS NEW CON RISK. WHICH
REYES CONSTITUTE CAN. WILL TO
COME SPEECH. ONTAP RESTRICTIONS
BUT IT'S THE SAME BAND
BACKGROUND ANY IMAGE WELL ARE
CALL AVERAGE PEACH. AND WHEN
THAT THE COPY WHAT IS TO AS TO
APPETITE NAME BY NUMBER.
CENTRAL HAD DONE WE QUESTION
WHETHER IT UNDERSTATES THE
CONSTITUTION CONCERNS THE CELL
PRESENT. OVER AND OVER THE
COURSE OF THE WORLD BUT- EVEN
THOSE ARE A RESTRICT. SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT ADVERTISE AN
AFFAIR AND THE MANNER TO THAT
OF OTHER BITS. SHE HAS BEEN AND
THAT'S MEMBERS SUPPORT THE OF
ALL THE- TO PROMOTE POT MISTER.
AND IT TO. FOR THE LOCAL STATE
STATUTES OUR MEMBERS. FOR
QUOTES WITH THEIR- REFLECTS
CHARACTER AND CONCERN ABOUT.
THEY ADVERTISED WITH. COMPANIES
GO EVEN CHECK AND EDITORIAL
COSTS. INSURANCE THE RIGHT TO
RICH AVERAGE THAT ARE MOSTLY.
BY LOOKING STANDARDS ARE
FEATURED AT. BEYOND WITH A LOT
OF BY. I'M NOT OR SOMETHING TO
THE CAN OF. THROUGH THE STATE.
HOWEVER THE RESTRICTION KONTEN
HERE SO FAR BEYOND THOSE OF. TO
ANY OTHER LEGAL. WHETHER
INTENDED ADULTS. FOR THE PUBLIC.
WITH ME AN ATTORNEY. BY AS LONG
DEALS ABOUT CHIEF COUNSEL.
FORTY YEAR AGO IN BUILDING
RADIO ISSUE. YES WAY A
RESPECTFUL ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
ON. EIGHTY TWO SEVEN THREE. YOU
VERY MUCH MR OVER IS AMY
JENKINS ON THE PHONE. YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMY
ON THE OF THE- CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IF IT. ALSO AND I TO
AB YOU CAN THREE WELL THE APRIL
TWENTY FIFTH AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE LANGUAGE THAT. BEING ALL
CANNABIS BILLBOARD ADVERTS THE
BILL ANTI IS. ANYONE HERE TO
CHANGE THE SAME LAWS AND
REGULATIONS ARE EQUALLY
RESTRICTIVE AS THEY RELATE TO
CANNABIS ADVERTISING
PROHIBITING SPECIFIED CONTENT
AS WELL AS ANY ADVERTISING ON
CITY STREETS WITHIN A THOUSAND
FEET AND DAY CARE CENTERS THESE
A COUPLE OF PLAYGROUND.
NONETHELESS AB TWO SEVEN THREE
FURTHER THINK THAT LEGAL
CANNABIS EVEN MORE PROHIBITED
ADVERTISING STANDARDS. ANY
OTHER REGULATED AGE RESTRICTED
PRODUCT OR SERVICE ALL LEGAL
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO COMMERCIAL FREE SPEECH
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO CONVEY
INFORMATION TO CONSUMERS THE
LONG IT IS NOT FRAUDULENT OR
ILLEGAL AND WHILE IT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE TO IMPOSE SOME
RESTRICTIONS TO ADVANCE AN
OVERALL GOAL. OF PROTECTING YOU
FROM EXPOSURE TO CANNABIS
DENYING ADULT CONSUMERS FACTUAL
INFORMATION ABOUT PRODUCTS AND
PRICES ON REASONABLE AB TWO
SEVEN THREE ALSO IMPOSES OVERLY
HARSH PENALTIES FOR ANY
VIOLATIONS IDENTIFIED BY THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL. AND
REMOVE ANY DISCRETION CURRENTLY
PERMITTED UNDER EXISTING LAW BY
MANDATING THAT ANY ADVERTISING
VIOLATIONS ARE SUBJECT TO A
LICENSE SUSPENSION FOR ONE YEAR
IMPOSING SUCH A PENALTY IT'S
PROBLEMATIC AND SHOULD BE LEFT
TO THE DISCRETION OF THE
BUREAU. LASTLY EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
THREE INCLUDES LANGUAGE THAT
UNREASONABLY VILIFIED THE LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY SUCH LANGUAGE
IS OPINION BASED ON
UNSUBSTANTIATED EVERYTHING
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT
COMMISSIONED BY THE INSURANCE
INSTITUTE FOR HIGHWAY SAFETY
FONG LEGAL CANNABIS OPERATORS
TAKE MARKETING SALES TO MINORS
EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY. IN FACT
RESEARCHERS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CHICAGO. BECAUSE OF A LEGAL
CALIFORNIA RETAILER ALLOWING AN
INDIVIDUAL INTO THEIR PRACTICE
WITHOUT PROPER AGE VERIFICATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR-
SUPPORT. JUST RATTLE YOU I
REQUEST YOU KNOW BUT TODAY I
APPRECIATE THE MUCH. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE I'VE BEEN IN A- TO
THE TWO SEVEN THREE ON THE
LINES. GIVEN UP IN OF AB TWO
THREE MAY PRESS ONE AT THEN. WE
WERE GO TO LINE OF ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS MARK
FOR THAT THAT BE A- REPRESENT
CLEAR CHANNEL OUTDOOR BILLBOARD
COMPANY- WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE BUT TO NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M CLINT
OLIVIER THE CEO OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUSINESS FEDERATION
OPPOSING THIS BILL ALONG WITH
THE VALLEY INDUSTRY AND
COMMERCE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE SILICON VALLEY
ORGANIZATION IN EIGHT OTHER
BUSINESS GROUPS AFTER THIS
HEARING WE WILL REVIEW THESE
NEW AMENDMENTS BUT THEY STILL
SOUND VERY RESTRICTIVE. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO
TO A LINE OF IT TOO IS SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICOLE. WITH COULD ADVOCATE
REPRESENTS BILLION FOR AND CAN
ACROSS IN OUR- TO EIGHTY CENTS
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AN EXTRA BOTTLE OF
THREE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE
TURNER PRESIDENT OF THE WEEK
FOR BURKE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DISABLED VETERANS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO THE UNAMERICAN
STIGMATIZING CENSORSHIP-
REPRESENTED BY. EIGHTY THREE
SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU AND NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF THREE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS TRACY
STEVENS WITH GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF NATURE IN
SACRAMENTO AND BODY AND MIND IN
LONG BEACH AND SAN DIEGO ALSO
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE OF THREE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS OVER TO LINE OF THREE OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU SHARON MEMBERS MONEY ON
KELLY RYAN ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
CANNABIS FOR CONSUMER SAFETY
COALITION STATE TIME OF
PRESENTING A LARGE COLLECTION
OF LIFE OF CANNABIS BUSINESSES
AND ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
SILICON VALLEY CANNABIS LINES
UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION JERRY ABSTRACT AND
FIFTY FIVE OTHER BUSINESSES.
AND ORGANIZATIONS WE ASK YOU TO
OPPOSE AB TWO SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF THREE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK HERE KATIE MAY FALL BY
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND COMPLIANCE FOR PERFECT
UNION AT ONE OF THE LARGEST
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
OPERATORS MISTY AND MURDER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF THREE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO SO LINE OF THREE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
ZERO MEMBERS MY NAME IS EDWIN
LOMBARD ON THE FIRST OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE
OPPOSE- AB- TWO SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ACROSS THE LINE OF THREE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS- MISTER CHAIRMAN GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF WEED MAPS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO A. B.
TWO SEVEN THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CONNECT TO THE
ALAINA TO FIVE YOUR LINE OPEN.
HEARING WILL. MY USER FIVE YOUR
LINE OF THE- WITH MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS NATALIA DID EITHER
DON'T IN THE LONGER. ALL AGE GO
TO HAVE A. EIGHT THANK YOU AND
NEXT GO TO LINE UP THREE ONE
YOUR LINE IS A- RIGHT. THANK
YOU MAY AND SHARE COMMON OUR
THE TRIGGER THE LAND SOCIAL.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA BOTTLE LINE
OF TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHAT THANK YOU FOR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT THANK
YOU NEXT STRUGGLE TO LINE OF
THREE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAITLYN
O'NEILL WITH THESE TECHNOLOGIES
CALLING IN OPPOSITION YOU
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NXR GO TO LINE
UP TO NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS WILSON
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION A GRASS
RELIANT THOSE CHILDREN TEND
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS REPS
THEY NEARLY HALF A MILLION
EMPLOYERS- OVER FOUR MILLION
PLEASE L. A. COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK GOD SO LINE OF THREE
OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GREG COLEMAN LIAM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CONTRA COSTA NORMAL-
AND ALSO- MEDICINAL
LOCATIONS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO SEVENTY THREE AS
AMENDED WHICH ARE STILL OF THE
BAN ON AFFECTED MARKETING FOR
LEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TIMELINE
OF THREE ALL THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KATIE AND THE JAPANESE LICENSE
AMERICA AND FOUNDER OF THE REAL
ARE AT AS WELL AS A CO FOUNDER.
EQUITY OWNERS AND WORKERS
ANOTHER. AT THE BLACK- WE ARE
ALREADY. POSITION TO COMPETE IN
THE INDUSTRY AND I HAVE A
QUESTION. OF. EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
ARE NOT GOING THE LINE OF THREE
TWENTY SIX YEAR ONE IS OPEN. A
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DAVID GOLDMAN I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAPTER OF THE
PRIMARY DEMOCRATIC CLUB THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE INTRODUCED
DO NOT SOLVE OUR CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL THEREFORE WE STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY THREE. ALONG WITH
OPERATION FEEDBACK BERRY
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS SAN
DIEGO AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS
LEGAL WARRIORS CALIFORNIA
NORMAL AND THE VETERANS
CANNABIS COALITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
BENEFITING POLICY CHRISTIAN
ATTITUDE ON BEHALF OF LAMAR
ADVOCATING BILL AFTER ADVOCATE
GENERAL CORPS ADVERTISING AND
MEADOW OUTDOOR ADVERTISING IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND THREE. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT ONE OF THREE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
TERRY WORSHAM I'M CALLING IN TO
EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWO SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU
AND ACCESSIBLE TO LINE OF THREE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS I'M
A LITTLE OF THAT IN THE
CANNABIS SOCIAL EQUITY BRAND
PICO. I'M HERE TO REPRESENT THE
SOCIAL EQUITY COMPANIES THAT
ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY THREE I
THANK BROUGH BLACK STAR FARMS
CLOUDNINE JAMES HENRY AT THAT
DROWNED. KDP RESERVE NEW LIFE
CALIFORNIA KINGSTON MORAL AND.
ON THE GO FLOWER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WHICH IS BEACON OPPOSITION OR
IN THE COMMITTEE OOMS WHEN
THEY BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CAN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. THIS
BOOK. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY
MISTER BERMAN SAID BY MR
MCCARTY QUESTION FROM A SIMILAR
BLUE. YEAH I FRANKLY I'M NOT
SURE WHERE I AM ON THIS BILL-
BUT- ONE THING GOD THAT THE
AUTHORS AT NIGHT. WONDERING IF
YOU COULD- ARTICULATE A LITTLE
BIT TO. A FURTHER ON ON. TOPIC
IT'S DISTURBING TO ME THAT.
APPARENTLY THERE BEEN NO
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
AUTHOR AND- OPPONENTS AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S- CONSIDERABLE
OPPOSITION HERE- THIS IS A- I
THINK THE BILL. IS ABOUT A
LEGITIMATE TOPIC AND SO IT'S OF
CONCERN TO ME THAT THERE- MAY
HAVE BEEN NO CONVERSATIONS. I'M
GONNA GET OUT OF THE PROPONENTS
IS THAT THE CASE- THANK YOU FOR
THAT A QUESTION ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AND GUESTS WE HAVE
REACHED OUT MULTIPLE TIMES
SINCE THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THIS PROCESS AND- SINCE THIS
BILL HAS BECOME ABOUT. CONTENT
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE UNABLE TO
HAVE A DIALOGUE WITH THE
OPPONENTS AND I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT THE WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT
THE BUSINESS OPPOSITION SAYING
THAT THEY HAVEN'T EVEN READ THE
AMENDMENTS. WHICH WERE QUITE
SUBSTANTIAL IT IS DISAPPOINTING
THAT THEY WOULD CALL IN AND
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS TIME SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IRWIN DO WISH TO CLOSE I
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS A FEW OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP
FIRST OF ALL THERE WAS THAT
ISSUE ABOUT WHETHER THERE IS A-
A CONSTITUTIONAL UP- ISSUES.
AND THAT WAS ADDRESSED A VERY
ELOQUENTLY BY THE- COMMITTEE
STAFF AND- THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THIS NEEDS TO BE NARROWLY
TAILORED AND- WE BELIEVE. THAT
IT IS SECONDLY- WHEN ALL THE
OPPONENTS ARE TALKING ABOUT-
THAT THIS IS GOING TO- AFFECT
THEIR BUSINESSES THEY ALSO
SHOULD REMEMBER THE PROMISE
THAT THEY MADE WHEN PROP SIXTY
FOUR PASSED AND IT WAS WRITTEN
BY. THE OPPONENTS THAT THEY
WOULD NOT BE MARKETING TO
CHILDREN AGAIN WE DO NOT NEED
TO EXPAND. THE LEGAL MARKET ON
THE BACKS OF. CHILDREN THIRD-
THERE WAS A COMMENT THAT THIS
WOULD ONLY ALLOW TOMBSTONE
TYPE. ADVERTISING I'M NOT SURE
EXACTLY I ASSUME THAT JUST
MEANS BLOCK LETTERS LIKE ON A
TOMBSTONE. BUT THERE ARE PLENTY
OF THE BILLBOARDS THAT WOULD
QUALIFY AS A MATTER OF FACT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM WOULD AS
LONG AS THEY DON'T ADVERTISE
SPECIFIC. PRODUCTS OR INCLUDE
DEPICTIONS OF- A MARIJUANA WANT
TO STOP THE USE THE USE OF
CARTOON CHARACTERS AND OTHER
ITEMS THAT ARE. OF ENTICING TO
CHILDREN SINCE THE LEGALIZATION
OF ADULT USE OF CANNABIS
THERE'S BEEN AN 18% INCREASE IN
THE LIKELIHOOD OF LIFETIME USE
AND A 23% INCREASE IN THE PAST
THIRTY DAY USE. AMONG
ADOLESCENTS IN CALIFORNIA
MARKETING TO CHILDREN WORKS
THAT'S WHY BIG TOBACCO DID IT.
THAT'S WHY THE ALCOHOL INDUSTRY
DID IT AND I THINK IT'S TIME
FOR SOME- COMMONSENSE RULES TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF CONTENT
SHOULD BE ALLOWED- FOR A DRUG
THAT MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
OF ALL AGES- SEE ON BILLBOARDS
EVERYDAY SO WITH THAT. AGAIN MR
SURE YOU WEREN'T HERE AT THE
BEGINNING I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE EXTENSIVE WORK THAT
YOU DID ON. THIS BILL AND- WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- AGAIN MY TECHNOLOGY THE
HARD TO IGNORE JUST WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE STAFF TO WORKING
WITH YOUR OFFICE. AND I KNOW
THAT YOU AND I HAVE PERSONALLY
HAD MORE CONVERSATIONS THAN I
WOULD HAVE LIKED ON THIS BILL-
BUT- TO HELP INFORM MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THE INITIAL BILL
INTRODUCTION WAS THAT OF
BANNING BILLBOARDS- AND IN
CONVERSATION TO TRY TO GET TO
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT- THIS
AND NOW WITH RESPECT TO
CONTENT. AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WILLINGNESS TO
WORK AND TACKLE THESE ISSUES SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SRE THAT THE
POLICY IS IMPLEMENTED CORRECTLY
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTED. TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD WHICH IS WHY THIS
DOESN'T OR DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND AGAIN WANT
TO COMMEND YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING WILLING TO ADDRESS
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT BUT
ALSO. OPEN TO HELPING TO
FINESSE THE LANGUAGE AS IT
MOVES FORWARD AND STAYING
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
INDUSTRY AND ALL IMPACTED
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE SO WITH THAT
THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- THERE'S BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO SEVEN THREE IRWIN TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW- HI FLORA THE VOTING.
FULLER NOT TURNING A- BERMAN
BERMAN HI BLOOM. CHEN. QIU
CUNNINGHAM. DALY FONG. GIPSON
GRAYSON. HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY
MCCARTY I- WHEN I MEDINA.
MULLIN SALAS SALAS HI CHANGE.
FIVE FIVE ZERO KNOWS FIVE ICE
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SOMEONE IRWIN- NOW
MOVE ON TO FOLLOW ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN. THIS
IS IT A. B. FOUR ZERO SEVEN BY
SIMILAR SALAS SO IT'S ALSO YOU
READY PERCENT 2% GREAT THIS
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AB
FOUR OH SEVEN WILL EXPAND THE
ACCESS QUALITY EYE CARE BY
AUTHORIZING OPTOMETRISTS TO
TREAT. ADDITIONAL CONDITION
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS
OPTOMETRISTS USED. THERAPEUTIC
PHARMACEUTICAL AGENTS TO
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT. ACQUIRED
BLEPHARITIS IS ALSO KNOWN AS
DROOPY EYELID. AMATEUR PIA AND
FRIZZ BY EUROPAEA. WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE I
DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
THE PHONE IT'S- TERRY MCHALE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BREVITY AND WILL BE
OPEN UP THE LINES HAS BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND WILL OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. MR MCHALE
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES B.
SEVENTY IS APPRECIATED PLEASE
PERCENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
CHAIRMAN WELCOME. THANK YOU-
THE OPTOMETRIST THE
OPHTHALMOLOGIST BEGAN MEETING
IN THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THEY HAVE
DONE IS TO ADVANCE THE SCOPE OF
LEGISLATION IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWS THE USE OF THE DRUGS
TECH CAUGHT TECHNOLOGY CAN
TREATMENT THIS IS A VERY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN THE PAST I WILL KEEP IT
BRIEF AND JUST ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE VERY MISTER MCHALE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC LINES
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS WISHING TO SIMPLY
SIGNIFIED THEIR SUPPORT BY
GIVING US THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF THEY WISH TO DO
SO. GIVE YOUR PART OF AB PORRO
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN THERE
OF YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
OH SEVEN. WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
THE I. TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE TWO FOUR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GRAHAM ONLY
BECOME AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. ON THE
PHONE LINES WHICH IS BEGIN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME THE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. FOUR ZERO SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IF YOU AT THE TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SEEM THEN THAT
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
SECOND AS A MEMBER OF A SALAS
WILL MOVE WITH THAT. MUSIC
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FOUR OH SEVEN SALAS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA HI ARAMBULA.
BERMAN BERMAN I BLOOM LOOM HI
CHAN CHAN HI Q. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DELI DELI HI FONG.
FONG I GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA HI MULLIN. SALAS SALAS
HI TEAM. FORTY NINE ZERO KNOWS
FOURTEEN EYES BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CLOSE WILL
THEN MOVE INTO FALL ORDER AGAIN
AND- THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN. WITH A
SERIES OF SUNSET BILLS. ARE
THESE ARE GONNA COMMITTEE BILLS
WITH A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ON BOTH SIDES ON THE NEXT-
COMING BILL PRESENTATIONS AND
ATTEND THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR
VICE CHAIR FOR ME TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
PRESENTING I'D NEVER SIXTEEN
MEMBERS PROFESSIONS AND
RELEASED IN NURSING. A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A COLLEGE IN MEMBERS-
FOR SO THIS IS A C. THESE ARE
SERIES OF BILL PRESENTATIONS ON
THE SUNSET HEARINGS MANY OF YOU
HAVE ATTENDED A SPECIFICALLY
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS AND
SPENT A SIGNIFICANT TIME TO.
FLUSH OUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND PRIORITIZING CONSUMER
PROTECTION FOR STUFF LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
ALICE'S AND ALSO WANT TO THANK-
A SUMMER FONG AND DOLLY THE
SPECIFICALLY ON THE
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING
LICENSING TIME LINES AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THOSE TO ALL
AUTHORS AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT. AND ARE
JUST WORK IN THIS EFFORTS ON
THE LINE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- IS THE EXECUTIVE
OURS OFFICER FOR THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
MODERATOR CAN WE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU ARE A PART OF AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. YEAH. ONE ZERO
APPEARED SUPPORT. I AM IN
SUPPORT EXCEPT OKAY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOUR LINE IS
ALREADY OPEN IF YOUR WITNESS
CORRECT THANK YOU. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MY NAME IS LAURA NOW WE
ARE THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING- I WAS ASKED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU GUYS MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINES. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT AT THE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN
THE CHAMBER. SEEING NONE. OF
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES. DO YOU HAVE HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION MAKE YOU AT THE TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH C. N. O.
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM OR IN THE REMOTE ROOMS ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. N. O. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER APPS
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL WHEN. I'LL MAKE A
MOTION. SIX AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TWO PRION BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
LOW HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA BY
FLORA I ARAMBULA. BERMAN BERMAN
NIGHT BLOOM BLOOM HI CHAN. CHAN
HI QIU. CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY
HI FONG FONG I GIPSON. GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN HI MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN. SALAS. TEN
TíNH HI. TWELVE ISER ANNOUNCED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I BELIEVE
THAT- BILL OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE HAS
RELEASED A PHARMACY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS AGAIN I WANT TO- CALL
OUT A SIMILAR GRAYSON AND
SIMILAR DOLLY FOR SPECIFICALLY
COMING TO OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS ON A REGULAR BASIS
EVERY TIME WITHOUT FAILURE IN
PERSON- BUT IT JUST GOES TO
SHOW THEIR COMMITMENT TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION IN THE
DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS BEFORE US
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY- AND IT
IS YOU KNOW. EVERY SINGLE
PROVISION IN THIS BILL IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE ISSUES
THAT WERE ANALYZED IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER THAT WE
PUBLISHED IN MARCH. OF LAST
YEAR. ADDITIONALLY MANY OF
THESE ISSUES WERE DISCUSSED IN
OUR OVERSIGHT HEARINGS THAT WE
HAD. IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR
WE CONTINUE. WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE BOARD OF PHARMACY THE
SENATE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
MOVING THROUGH A NUMBER OF
THESE ISSUES AND YOU'VE OUR
DEEP COMMITMENT TO IRON OUT
THESE ISSUES AS IT MOVES
FORWARD IN THIS FIRST COMMITTEE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MATT A MODERATE
TO HAVE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY THREE OF MY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE SEVEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AND ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE TO KEEP IT UP.
AND THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF. AB.
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE. IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
THREE WE WILL GO TO THE LINE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ABOUT LINE
OF TWO EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO JENNIFER MANLEY
BUT THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS MICHELLE
READ THAT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION WE WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH US AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE BILL
IF IT MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH C. IN
ANY SUPPORT IN THE CHAMBERS
SEEN NINE MADAM. A MODERATE TO
HAVE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE NEAR HERE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO MEMBERS MAYES JENNIFER
SNYDER WITH THE RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION I CAN MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS. GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE AT
JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS SITUATION.
WE UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW I
JUST HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON EIGHTEEN
THIRTY THREE. OUR CONCERN
CENTER AROUND ONE SPECIFIC
PROVISION RELATED FINES AND
ENFORCEMENT FOR PARK TO
COMPANIES- ALTHOUGH
CONCEPTUALLY THIS ISSUE AND AS
THE OFFICE SAID HAVE WAS
BRIEFLY DISCUSSED IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS THAT. BOX BECAUSE
THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE SEEN A
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE- SO AS AS THE
LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY PROPOSED
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH FINES UP
TO A MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PHARMACY COMPANY THAT OWNS OR
MANAGES MAYBE JUST ONE PHARMACY
WITH. POSSIBLE MULTIPLE
VIOLATIONS. OF THE CONCEPT OF
HOLDING PRIVATE CORPORATIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR LICENSE FEES BY
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY IT NEW
AND UNPRECEDENTED AND NOT A
CONFLICT WE KNOW OF ANOTHER
STATE SO WE ARE GREATLY
APPRECIATED OF THE AUTHORED.
BACK WILLINGNESS AND INTEREST
IN ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM- TREATMENTS. IN THE NEAR
FUTURE THANK. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FOR UP THE AND YOU AT
THE MODERATOR ACTUALLY THINK
WANT TO GO BACK TO SOME THE
GRIPPED WITNESS PRIMER
WITNESSES. OF A FIFTEEN THIRTY
THREE I WANT TO GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY. OKAY HERE LINES
ARE OPEN. MORNING THIS IS A
LOCATOR GRANTED THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE ON
STAFF ABOUT YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND CAREFULLY VALUATION OF
POURING IT ON SECOND COURT IN
THE IDENTIFIED ISSUES AS BARKER
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS IN
1-815-334-0360 THE COURT. THE
BOARD CENTER EXPANSION AND
INCLUSION THAT'S RECOMMENDED
POLICY CHANGES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACKIE GRAY
WELL LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH
YES HE W. WESTERN STATE CAPITOL
I'M HERE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
AND EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE
ON BEHALF OF A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA SEVERAL THOUSAND OF
HIM OUR PHARMACISTS AND
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS. FIRST
FIFTY W. WOULD LIKE TO THANK
CHAIRMAN MILE AND THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR ALL THEIR WORK
ON THIS YEAR'S BOARD OF
PHARMACY FUNDS THAT RUBIO. A
FINANCIAL PENALTY MUST BE
CONSEQUENTIAL ENOUGH TO DISPLAY
THAT CONTENT THAT IS HARMFUL
HOWEVER THE MAXIMUM FINE TO
BOARD OF PHARMACY CAN IMPOSE ON
A LARGE CORPORATE PHARMACY FOR
A PATIENT HUNTING CONTACT IT'S
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FIRST
FOUR PERSPECTIVE THAT THE TOP
LIMIT AND SMALL CLAIMS COURT
NEEDLESS TO SAY THAT'S
EXTREMELY SMALL LEVEL OF FINES
DO NOT WORK TO PROMOTE
COMPLIANCE. FURTHERMORE THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY IS LIMITED TO
FIGHTING EACH PHARMACY
INDIVIDUALS MAKING IT DIFFICULT
TO HOLD STORED UNDER COMMON
OWNERSHIP ACCOUNTABLE AND TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY BROUGHT TO THREE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SAYS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE THREE
BIGGEST RETAIL CHAIN FAILING TO
PROPERLY PROVIDE PERSONAL
CONSULTATION ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUG THE PATIENT. ALL THIRTY
MAJOR RETAILERS ARE ULTIMATELY
FIND BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
REPORTS TO COMPLY WITH
CALIFORNIA'S STANDARDS FOR
PATIENT COMPLICATIONS YEAH
ACCORDING TO THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY VIOLATIONS REGARDING
PATIENT CONSULTATIONS CONTINUE
TO FIGHT CITATIONS ISSUED BY
THE BOARD OF FIRE DEPARTMENT
SEEK AND FIND THE. FACT BY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOR ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
NOT BY PROBABLY A- HIGHER FINE
FOR THINGS BYERLY'S. FOR
PERMITTING HIGHER ONLY FOR
REPEAT AND VIA. OF MEANT TO
PROTECT YOUR- TO ARE NOT. THE
DOOR FOR PROPOSED A INCREASE
KIND ABOUT FIRST. AND BY. OF
LAW BUT IN THE SAME TWELVE MY
WHERE WE FIVE PERIOD.
ENFORCEMENT ACTION THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THE ON A ALWAYS
POSSIBLE SIDE OF BY THE PENALTY.
IN AB FOR THIRTY THREE ARE.
NEEDED TO PER EACH AND FOR.
AFTER ALL YEARS WE'VE THAT WE
WERE. THEY WERE YOUR THAT ON
EIGHTY FIFTH THIRTY. THE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF OUR GONNA
MOVE BACK TO OP. IN THE CHAMBER
ANY OP. TO IF. AB FIFTY THIRTY
THREE. SENIOR ANY QUESTIONS THE
CA. SEEING NONE- I WILL JUST
EXPRESSED A COUPLE THINGS ON
THIS THERE IS A FEW- CONCERNS I
DO HAVE IN THIS BILL I AM A
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND THAT
MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE I HAVE
RESPECT FOR YOU AND YOU
COMMITTEE STAFF ON ON GETTING
SOME OF THESE THINGS WORKED OUT
WITH SOME OF THE OPPOSITION SO
I KNOW WE'LL GET THERE AND IF
ANY OF THOSE THINGS DON'T QUITE
DEVELOPING WE CAN HOLD OFF ON
THE FLOOR BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT BRING THIS FORWARD AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR IT
DEEPLY COMMITTED TO DOING SO AS
IT MOVES TO THROUGH THE PROCESS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ASSERTING
MISTER GRAYSON AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY THREE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW HIGH FLOOR HIGH FLOOR I
ARAMBULA. BERMAN BERMAN I BLOOM
BLOOM HI CHEN. CHIU CUNNINGHAM
DALLI DALLI HI FONG FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN HI MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN SALAS TAKING
TíNH HI. TWELVE AYE ZERO KNOWS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL HOLD
THAT THE ROLE OF PERHAPS A
MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
NINETEEN EIGHTY B. E. FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD SUNSET.
AND AGAIN WANT TO THANK ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO- HAVE JOINED US
IN HELPING TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THE NECESSARY PROTECTIONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. MADAME
MODERATOR. ANYWAY COMMITTEE
NUMBER. A MEMBER OF THE FIRM
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT THEIR THE
BATTERY MEDICAL BOARD I'D LIKE
TO POINT EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF EVERYTHING
INCLUDED IN THE BILL WHICH
EVERYBODY THE BILL WOULD PROVE
HOW TO BE PROTECTED AND SERVE
OUR LIKE THE DEFENSE SECRETARY-
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUBPOENA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
THREE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES A GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KAREN LAYING
ON TOP OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION NOT IN
SUPPORT TODAY BUT I'M NOT
TRYING TO OPPOSE IT EITHER WE
REALLY ARE JUST ASKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE. PLEASE STAY
WITH US AND TRYING TO RESOLVE
THE ISSUE OF THE- DEPENDENT
REGULATION THAT WILL APPLY TO
ALL SOLDIERS IN CALIFORNIA
RELATED TO HAVING A
VETERINARIAN AND THE
VETERINARIAN PROMISE PERMIT.
WE'VE ARTICULATED THE CONCERN
WE HAVE FOR A QUARTER OF THE
SHELTER THE STATE NOT BE ABLE
TO MEET THAT HOWEVER AND OTHER
SHELTERS. VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT TO DO WHEN THEIR
VETERINARIANS ON VACATION OR
THEY HAVE TURNOVER IN THEIR
STAFF AND OTHER STATES TO TREAT
ANIMALS COMING IN THE DOOR TO
THEIR SHELTERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
OBLIGATED TO PROVIDE THEM CARE
AND THEY DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
BETTER NAZARIAN. ONSITE ISSUES
BEEN IDENTIFIED IN MULTIPLE
TIMES THAT REVIEWS AND YET NOT
RESOLVED THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS
THAT THIS TIME AROUND THERE IS
A PENDING REGULATION WHICH
MAKES RESOLUTION OF THIS ISSUE
INCREDIBLY URGENT FOR ASKING
YOU TO PLEASE NOT CONCLUDE THAT
SUNSET. NICER THIS YEAR WITHOUT
ADDRESSING IT IN A WAY THAT
SHELTERS CAN MOVE FORWARD IN
DOING THEIR OBLIGATED PASSED TO
TAKE CARE AND LOOK COMING IN
OUR DOOR WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S.
A VETERINARIAN ON SITE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO FOR
THIS QUEUE THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE IS SUPPORTING
THE CHAMBERS IN THE GALLERY C.
N. NONE OF FROM A REMOTE WITH
THE STATION. CNN MEMORY TO HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION. TO AB. FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF ABFIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER SEEN
ON ANY OPPOSITION FROM THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY ROOMS SEEN
NINE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. CNN MISTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM SECTOR POLITICAL. AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS DO
YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LOW HIGH LOW HIGH FLOOR HIGH
FLOOR HI ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI
BERMAN. BERMAN HI BLOOM. BLOOM
HI CHEN. CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY HI FONG.
FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. WHEN I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA INA
HI MULLIN. SALAS. SALAS HI KING
FIFTEEN HI. SIXTY NINE ZERO
NOTES THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY OF PRESENT
THE SENSIBLE FOR THE BORDER
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS WOULD
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED ANALYSIS AS WELL AS A
COMMAND A SIMILAR CHEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING TO WORK
OUT A NUMBER OF ISSUES AND
ADDRESSED THE BOARD'S BACKLOG
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON-
ALONG WITH THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER- WE COMMEND EXECUTIVE
OFFICER BECOME A GOOD YOU ALSO
FOR BEING COMMUNICATED WITH
THIS COMMITTEE. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM OPERATED WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX.
REPORTS OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN THERE
APPEARED SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX. AND WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY SUPPORT
IN THE CHAMBER SEE NON ANY
SUPPORTER REMOTE TESTIMONY
ROOMS SEEM NINE. MATT OPERATE
TO HAVE ANY IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE SEVEN ZERO
FOUR IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER SEEN
NONE. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SIGNON MISTER
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE CRITICAL
WE NEED FOR WE NEED A MOTION A
SECOND PLEASE. BERMAN AND
ARAMBULA. AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA FLORA HI ARAMBULA
MERIMBULA I BERMAN BERMAN NIGHT
BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHEN CHEN HI
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY HI
FONG FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON HI
GRAYSON. GRAYSON HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN. SALAS SALAS EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN HI. FIFTY NINE ZERO NO
THANK YOU REMARKABLE DOUBLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND NOW
MOVING ON TO AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE FINAL
SUNSET BILL- FOR TODAY THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL WHICH WOULD EXTEND THE
COUNCIL BY ONE YEAR. AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW DURING OUR SENSE OF
HEARING THE COUNSEL OF FOR THIS
COUNCIL WE DISCUSSED A NUMBER
OF ISSUES IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER AND EXPLAINED WHY THAT
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN SOME THAT
ALLOCATED. TOWARDS MOVING
TOWARDS MASSAGE LICENSURE BY
BOARD. WHILE THERE ARE
POTENTIAL FLAWS IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM AS WE DISCUSSED WE ARE
G. CONSIDERING THE CREATION OF
A NEW LICENSE OR BOARD AND A
NUMBER OF FACTORS TO CONSIDER
THAT ARE MORE APPROPRIATELY
DISCUSSED THE SUNRISE PROCESS-
BUT AGAIN THIS IS A BILL.
ADDITIONALLY STATES THAT IT IS
OUR INTENT TO CONTINUE THESE
DISCUSSIONS THROUGHOUT THE SUN
RISE PROCESS OVER THE YEAR. I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
MY VERY OWN DISTRICT ATTORNEY
HERE IS HERE IN THE CHAMBERS A
TO TESTIFY A WHILE I MAY NOT
SEE HIM BACK AT HOME IN SILICON
VALLEY I SEE HIM UP HERE IN OUR
STATE CAPITOL. THAT'S THE KIND
OF DISTRICT ATTORNEY HE IS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM OPERATOR TO
HAVE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT FOR A
BI FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT- IT LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES THE
AIRLINES ARE OPEN. HELLO. THIS
IS DOCTOR JEFFREY KUHLMAN CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CANCER. YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR
JEFFREY FOREMAN AND ON THE
ELECTED CHAIR OF THE C. A. M.
P. CHEESE BOARD I WAS CHOSEN AT
AND T. A. EDUCATE OF THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. AND FOR
THIRTY SIX YEARS I WAS A
TENURED PROFESSOR OF PHYSICAL
EDUCATION AT DE ANZA COLLEGE IN
THE EARLY NINETIES I FOUNDED
AND BECAME COORDINATOR OF THE
PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE THERAPY
DEGREE AND CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS
AT ANZA. UNOPPOSED IN LESS
AMENDED TO THIS LEGISLATION MY
OPPOSITION IS TO THE BURDENSOME
EXPENSIVE AND INEFFECTIVE
ADOPTION OF A LICENSING BOARD.
TO REGULATE MASSAGE THERAPY.
THE TIME I GREW WITH AND T.
SUPPORT OF LICENSURE. THAT
SUPPORT PREDATED THE
LEGISLATURE'S DECISION TO
CREATE C. A. M. P. C. AND ALLOW
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THAT
TAKES ADVANTAGE. OF THE
TRANSPARENCY OF LOCAL AND STATE
COLLABORATION TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS. AND ADVANCE THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING OF
PROVIDERS. I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED
BY THE ASSERTIONS THAT SEEING
MTC IS NOT TRANSPARENT. DOES
NOT AFFORD DUE PROCESS IN THE
STATE CERTIFICATION OR
LICENSING AGENCY SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO CONFRONT THE GROOM
ISSUES OF EXPLOITATION. AND
SEXUAL TRAFFICKING. I'M ALSO
BOUGHT BY THE ALLEGATIONS
SUGGESTING THAT A LACK OF A
LICENSE PRECLUDES BILLING TO
MEDICARE FOR NON OPIOID PAIN
CONTROL TREATMENTS. ONE SUCH A
SUGGESTION IS PATENTLY FALSE WE
HAVE DOCUMENTATION TO VERIFY
THIS. SUNSET HAS BEEN THE
CONSTRUCTIVE EXPERIENCE IN THE
PAST THE C. A. M. P. C. I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. AND THE COMMITTEE TO
FURTHER PROTECT CONSUMERS BY
STRENGTHENING C. A. M. P. C. WE
RECEIVE SUPPORT LEVIN LETTERS
MULTIPLE SUPPORT LETTERS FROM
SOURCES AS VARIED AS DELAYS
SHERIFFS. POLICE CHIEFS AND
ETHNIC ASSOCIATION. WITH WHOM
WE'VE WORKED TO PROTECT
IMMIGRANTS WE HAVE SUPPORT FROM
SCHOOLS BUSINESSES AND EXPERTS
IN DEALING WITH SEX TRAFFICKING
LABOR TRAFFICKING AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR REALLY WONDERS YOUR TIME
SLOTS PLEASE. YES IN THE SHORT
TIME WE MADE A DIFFERENCE TO
BRING MASSAGE THERAPY OUT OF
THE SHADOWS AND INTO THE
MAINSTREAM WE LOOK TO IMPROVE
WE ASKED THE BILL BE AMENDED TO
WORK TOWARDS. PERFECTING C. A.
M. P. C. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
WAS IN OPPOSITION WE WERE GONNA
GO TO SUPPORT TO RDA JEFF ROSEN
YOU CAN STEP UP TO THE MIKE
SIR. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND CHAMBER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. A GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S JEFF ROSEN I'M THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. I'M HERE THIS
MORNING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. ONLY IF THE
LANGUAGE ISN'T PLACE TO DISCUSS
HOW TO ENHANCE THE
EXTRAORDINARY CAPACITY. OF CMT
C. WITH CMT C. WE HAVE A SYSTEM
IN PLACE THAT WORKS REMARKABLY
WELL. CMT C. ALLOWS FOR THE
GENTLEMAN THE SAUCE TO THRIVE
AND PROVIDE. RELAXATION AND
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. THE REPORTING PART
OF MANY CALIFORNIANS LIVES. AS
DA I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING THE COMMUNITY
SAFETY. AND I'M ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSED TO THE CREATION OF A
STATE BOARD FOR MASSAGE THERAPY
AND A STATEWIDE LICENSE. THE
CREATION OF A SLOW MOVING
BUREAUCRATIC SACRAMENTO CENTRIC
BOARD. THAT IS EXPENSIVE
PONDEROUS DISTANCE FROM LOCAL
INVOLVEMENT AND UNABLE TO.
RESPOND EFFECTIVELY TO THE
COMPLEXITIES IN THE MASSAGE
INDUSTRY. IS SIMPLY ABOUT IDEA.
AND WOULD BE A GIANT STEP
BACKWARD. I JOIN WITH POLICE
CHIEF LOCAL BUSINESSES
CONSUMERS AND GROUPS WHICH
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE. IN
SUPPORT OF CMT C. AND STRONGLY
AGAINST THE IDEA OF THE STATE
BOARD. AS DA I BECAME A
BELIEVER IN C. M. D. C. BY
WITNESSING FIRST HAND THE
COLLABORATION. AND EFFICIENCY
CMT C. BRINGS IN OUR BATTLE%
AGAINST SEX TRAFFICKING. A
STATE BOARD LACKS THE DEXTERITY
OF CMT C. AND WOULD OPEN THE
FLOODGATES OF HUMAN
EXPLOITATION. THE CMT C. MODEL
CREATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. IS AN ENVIABLE
EXAMPLE OF POWER COMMUNITIES
BENEFIT FROM A DEDICATED PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS. SEEM
TO SEE AS CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD
STANDARDS AND A DISCIPLINARY
MODEL BASED UPON DUE PROCESS.
THAT IS FAIR TRANSPARENT AND
PROTECTS THE COMMUNITY. DURING
THE TOUGHEST MOMENTS OF THE
COVERT PRIDE CRISIS. WE COULD
STILL RELY ON CMT C. TO ANSWER
THE CALL QUICKLY. AND RESPOND
BOTH QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
CMCC IS A MODEL THAT WORKS. I
BELIEVE THAT SEEM TO SEE CAN
WORK WITH MY FRIEND EVAN LOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND THIS
LEGISLATURE AS THEY HAVE. IN
PAST SUNSET HEARINGS TO CAN CAN
YOU TO AND- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DO HAVE A
CRISTINA- WHO WERE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT. YEAH THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRISTINA BROWN THE BACK HALF
OF THE AMERICAN FLAG THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. AMPA STRONGLY
FAVORS THE STATEWIDE LIFE
INSURER FIVE THERAPY CALIFORNIA
REPORTS THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FACT EXPAND
THE CONCEPT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WELL
CONSIDER LEGISLATION CREATING A
NEW STATE BOARD. OVERSEEING THE
PROSPERITY AND REQUIRING
LICENSURE. FROM THE FLASH THERE
FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA. IN HIS
MISSION IS ADVOCATE FOR FAIR
AND CAN PROFESSIONAL LIFE OF
THERAPY AND ALL FIFTY STATES AS
WELL AS THAT AUTHORITY.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY FIVE
STATES WITHOUT STATEWIDE LIKE
AND SHARE. THE PUBLIC HAS A
RIGHT TO EXPECT THEM FLASH
THEIR CAPACITY WHILE THE
PATIENT NEEDED TO PASS. LEE AND
SAFELY. LEGAL RECOGNITION OF
THE PRACTICE OF MASSAGE THERAPY
AND CLEARLY STATE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS TO PRACTICE OUR
EXPONENTIAL TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
THE PUBLIC AND EVERY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY WELL. AS A GROWING
PRESENCE WITHIN THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WILD NATIONAL
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM BUT JOSH
THERAPY IS RECOGNIZED BY BOTH
THE DEPARTMENT DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
ACTIVE TREATMENT FOR CHRONIC
PAIN. AS A RESULT WITHOUT THEIR
FEES INCLUDED INDIA TV EIGHTEEN
MANAGEMENT GUIDELINES. UNDER
THE COVERED SERVICE INDIA
DEVIATE THE QUALITY. THE I
HAVEN'T STOPPED LAST YEAR FIVE
TO YES MY POSITIONS WERE STATE
LICENSE SLASH THEIR. THE THING
FOR MEDICARE AND SERVICES HAS
RECOMMENDED AND THEN
RECOMMENDED AND PLAN BY GUIDE
IN THE- IT MASSAGE PROVIDER BY
STATE LIFE MASSAGE THERE SHOULD
BE SUPPLEMENTAL BY. WITHIN
MEDICARE ADVANTAGE PLAN.
SIMILAR WITH THERE BE NOTHING
ABOUT AS AN NOW FARM. APPROACH
TO PEMEX. SUPPORTED BY NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH THE
DEPARTMENT HAPPEN THEIR PAIN
HALF FORCETHE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF PHYSICIANS THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS.
AND THE JOINT COMMISSION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ON THE LINE. YOU'RE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HE I SUPPORT WITH
AMENDMENTS MY NAME IS TAMARA
WALKER AND I TOLD IN MINUTES
HOLLYWOOD CAREER COLLEGE A
SCHOOL WHICH OFFERS A MASSAGE
THERAPY PROGRAM- NAME AN
ORGANIZATIONAL I. SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE MTC AND
RATHER THAN CHANGING TO SOME
NEW. ORGANIZATION. PLEASE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TEN ANYONE ELSE
IS A LARGEST DAVID ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND WE OVER
TO ONE OF THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY SHOW YES
MY MARKET. I MARK EXYNOS PAST
MEMBER OF A NGA FOR THIRTY
THREE YEARS AMERICAN MASSAGE
THERAPY ASSOCIATION AND
PREVIOUS AIM TO YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE CFTC
BOARD FOR TEN YEARS I SUPPORT
THE CONTINUATION CNPC AND
OPPOSE LICENSING UNDERSTOOD
GIRL CHRISSY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOT TO GO TO
LINE OF A FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS MORE
IMPORTANT AND THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS DIRECTOR
FOR ASSOCIATED BODYWORK AND
MASSAGE PROFESSIONALS WHO GOT
OVER TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
STATEWIDE LICENSURE WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL FOR THE MASSAGE
THERAPIST. HAS MUCH AS AN
ORGANIZATION YES MA'AM. THANK
YOU NEXT SOBRE TO LINE OF FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DR BENJAMIN FROM THE
PRESIDENTIAL CALIFORNIA
METHODICAL APPROPRIATION AND ON
BEHALF OF MOBILE THIRTY MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA THOUGHT
BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA. WHICH
SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF THE
MPC AND OPPOSE THE LICENSING ON
THE STATE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO A
LINE OF FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DR
KATHLEEN POWELL I AM FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER ON SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF C. A. M. P.
AMPLE SUPPLY KEEPING UNDER
STATE GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE OF SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS TO BUY SOME TONER AND
PRESIDENT OF NATIONALISTIC
INSTITUTE THE FIRST CREDITED
AND LARGEST MASSAGE SCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA WITH SOME LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
SAN JOSE SACRAMENTO IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORTERS OF
THE CONTINUATION CFTC I'M NOT
LICENSES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE A
ONE OH FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS BILL ARMOR I'M
THE OWNER OF BURKE WILLIAMS AND
EMPLOYEE NEARLY ONE THOUSAND C.
A. M. P. C. CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST I SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION AND C. A. M. P. C.
AND OPPOSE STATE LICENSURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. Q. AND
MEXICO AT THE LINE OF THREE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I THINK YOU AGREE RETIRED CHECK
HERE ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY- WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL BUT
OPPOSED TO LIKE THE BORDER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THREE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH. MY NAME IS JUDY
CALVERT I'M THE PRESIDENT
JOHNSON WAS TRADED SOCIAIS
ASIAN REPRESENTING. SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FOSTER. M. SO WE CAN
OF CA CASEY ANNA HELLO
LICENSING UNDERSTATE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
UP FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ROSE
KLEIN I'M WITH AKKI ASIAN
WOMEN'S HOME IN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF BMTC. AND
OPPOSED BY THE THING UNDER
STATE GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE OF FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CHIEF RONALD LAWRENCE
OF CITRUS HEIGHTS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OR THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO POLICE CHIEFS- IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION
OF CNPC IN AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AND OPPOSE STATE
LICENSING UNDER STATE
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
UP TO FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO. LET'S GO HEAD TO
HEAD. NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE OPEN. THANK YOU FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CANNELLA MODERATOR WE CAN MOVE
ON AND NOT. LINE THREE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SURE YOU KNOW WHAT TOPIC THE
LISTENED AND CONTRACTING THAT
OCCURRED COUNTY REPRESENT
AGENCIES. THE SOLUTION
POLITICAL HELPS CLEAR COUNTY
WHERE COLLECTION JUST NAME FOR
MERRY. ADVERT AMERICA OPERATED
JUST CENTER WE SUPPORT TO
CONTINUE OF. INTERPOL AND
CREATES OF A STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
TO LINE OF THREE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
VAN ECK I'M RETIRED LIEUTENANT
FROM THE SAN JOSE POLICE
DEPARTMENT OR I MANAGE THEIR
FEDERALLY FUNDED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. FORCE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THAT
BEEN CONSULTING THE RESPONSE
TRACKING EVER SINCE AND
CURRENTLY TO HUMAN THE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FOR SAN MATEO
COUNTY. CALLING SUPPORT OF C.
PEAKING GREAT WORK AND WE
OPPOSE THEIR LIVES- OPPOSED
LIKE UNDER STATE LAW CHRISTIAN
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. IT'S A
COMPLICATED. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM MODERATOR.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK FOR OPPOSITION
HAD THERE'S A LOT OF TWEETERS
ON THE PHONE LINE SO ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION-
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
EIGHT ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF THREE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S SUSAN FLEMING. AND I AM.
AT AND T. MEMBER NCAA MEMBER
AND MY POSITION IS THAT- I
SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF THE
C. A. M. P. C. AND OPPOSED
LICENSING UNDER STATE
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY I LIKE
MANY OTHER EIGHTY MM. MEMBERS
AGREE NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOU. FOR GOING TO A LINE. OF
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS STACY DECLARE
I AM THE SOLE PROVIDER MASSAGE
THERAPIST AND AMPA MEMBER MY
POSITION ON AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AS OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
I HUMBLY REQUEST A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION TO C. A. M. P. C. AS
THE CERTIFYING AND SCHOOL
APPROVING REGULATORY BODY FOR
MASSAGE THERAPY THANK YOU SO
MUCH DO NOT AGREE WITH THE AND-
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE CHAMBERS WITH ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY SCENE
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ANDREW
GARSTEN I AM. A FOUNDER AND
BOARD MEMBER OF THE MASSAGE
ENVY CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT OVER
A HUNDRED FORTY LOCATIONS AND
AS SUCH WE'RE THE LARGEST.
AGGREGATION OF MASSAGE
BUSINESSES OF THE STATE THE
LARGEST EMPLOYER SEEM TO SEE
THERAPISTS BY. FACTOR
MAGNITUDES AND WE SERVE THE
PUBLIC. MORE THAN ANY OTHER
ENTITY IN THE CASE IN THE STATE.
WE ARE AGREEING WITH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE TESTIMONY
YOU'VE HEARD AT THE CMT C. MUST
CONTINUE. AND THAT WE OPPOSE
ANY LICENSURE WHATSOEVER- AND
I'D LIKE TO OFFER THAT IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR US I'VE
BEEN AROUND. DOING WORK WITH
THE MASSAGE INDUSTRY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE. TWO CENTRAL
SEEING TREMENDOUS. CHANGE OF
THAT TIME WITH HIM TO SEE
COMING TO THE STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY CONNECTION
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE THERAPY
COALITION- WE'RE A GROUP OF
SOME OF THE LEADING PROVIDERS
OF MASSAGE WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
T. C. OF THE CMT C. N. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING- WITH THIS
COMMITTEE- AND WITH THE CHAIR.
ON LOOKING TOWARDS POSSIBLE
IMPROVEMENTS OR ADJUSTMENTS IN
THAT PARTICULAR APPROACH AS
OPPOSED TO TAKING A STATE
LICENSING APPROACH WHICH WE
DON'T THINK WILL BE AFFECTED
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION ON.
THE GALLERY JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. SEE NON BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OH SORRY NAME AN ORGANIZATION
LADIES AND SUPPORT. YES YOU GO
TO THE MICROPHONE JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. CONNIE
CHAN FROM FOURTH IN CALIFORNIA.
I CURRENTLY HOLD TO STATE
LICENSES REAL ESTATE BROKERS
FROM DEPARTMENT REAL ESTATE FOR
FORTY USERS SO MA'AM WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT WE'VE HAD THE
PLENTY OF LIKE SUPPORT SO JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE WORK WE'RE GONNA. KEEP
IT MOVING. MY NAME IS CONNIE
CHAN I ON THE HEALING STATIONS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS
LAUREN MCLAUGHLIN I AM A
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST I
AM A MEMBER OF A BMP I AM A
SOLE PROPRIETOR AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE SUNSET OF CA TO
SEE. AND IT VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF LICENSURE YOU NEED
TO LISTEN TO THE ACTUAL.
MASSAGE THERAPIST NOT THE
PEOPLE THAT THROW TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS THAT YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TESTIMONY. OKAY SEE
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBERS
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEE NON MISTER
CHAIR- I WOULD JUST ECHO THE
SAME CONCERNS AS EVERYBODY ELSE
YOU KNOW I WAS WE WANT TO
CONTINUE. YOU KNOW THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IN PLACE BUT I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT STATE LICENSURE
BUT I KNOW ONCE AGAIN- YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THIS
ISSUE SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WANT
TO THANK OUR VICE CHAIR IN THIS
COMMITTEE FOR ALSO BEING
PRESENT DURING OUR SENSE THAT
HEARINGS I ALSO WANT TO THANK.
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN-
HIS COMMENTS WERE VERY
COMPELLING I LOOK FOR TO THE
CONTINUE CONVERSATION AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD IN THE POLICY
PROCESS. TO HEAR SOME OF THE
ISSUES TO BE ADDRESSED AND SOME
OF THE FORMS ACCORDINGLY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A-
WE NEED A SECOND. MISTER KING
BEDS CERTAINLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVENTY
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA NOT VOTING
FOR NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HYPE BERMAN. BERMAN I
BLOOM BLOOM AYE CHAN CHEN HI
CHU CHU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI DELHI DELHI HI
FONG. GIPSON GIPSON HI GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. HI MULLIN
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI TEAM
EIGHTEEN HI. SEVENTY NINE ZERO
S. SEVENTEEN ICE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS BACK- CONCLUDES THE
PRESENTATIONS FOR THE SUNSET
HEARINGS I WANT TO THANK AGAIN
OUR- COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
TIRELESSLY AND THROUGHOUT THE
WEE. HOURS OF THE MORNING ON
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
A STRONG A SENSE OF URGENCY ON
WITH RESPECT TO CONSUMER
PROTECTION SO AGAIN KUDOS TO
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE TWO FINAL
BILLS FOR PRESENTATION. AND
THEN WILL GO BACK INTO FILE
A FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN THIS
IS AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY
SUMMER COMING UP THIS DOESN'T
JOINED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
BOTH SIDES PLEASE FEEL FREE 2%
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COMMITTEE FOR DILIGENT WORK ON
THIS BILL. AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SIX WOULD WAIVE LICENSURE FEES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. FOR SPOUSES OF ACTIVE
MILITARY MEMBERS UNDER TWO
CONDITIONS ONE THEY ALREADY
HOLD A LICENSE IN ANOTHER
STATE. AND TWO THEY HAVE BEEN
RELOCATED DUE TO THEIR SPOUSES
MILITARY. SERVICE MILITARY
FAMILIES MOVE MORE OFTEN THAN
THEIR CIVILIAN COUNTERPARTS ON
AVERAGE EVERY TWO TO THREE
YEARS. AND RECENT STUDY FOUND
MILITARY SPOUSES EARN ABOUT 14%
LESS THAN THEIR CIVILIAN
COUNTERPARTS DUE TO
TRANSITIONAL. JOB COSTS IT'S MY
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT
THIS REPRESENTING VANDENBERG
AIRFORCE BASE AND- CAMP ROBERTS
ARMY NATIONAL GUARD. AND IF YOU
WILL INDULGE ME FOR A BRIEF
TWENTY SECOND STORY- MY AUNT
WAS MARRIED TO SOMEBODY IN THE
AIR FORCE. SHE STARTED OUT IN
MINOT NORTH DAKOTA. SHE WAS A
COSMETOLOGIST SHE WAS A HAIR
STYLIST. AND ABOUT ABOUT UNDER
TEN YEARS SHE MOVED FROM MY NOT
NORTH DAKOTA BOSTON
MASSACHUSETTS BOSTON. THE SANTA
MARIA CALIFORNIA TO VANDENBERG
AIRFORCE BASE. AND THEN FROM
SANTA MARIA CALIFORNIA TO
DENVER COLORADO. AND EACH TIME
SHE CHANGED SHE HAD TO GET RE
LICENSE IN THE STATE. SO THIS
IS FOR MY AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. AND I HAVE- YEAH I DO
HAVE A WITNESS SORRY ABOUT THAT.
WHICH IS DAN PIERCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
HERE TO SPEAK IT'S FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF
WHAT. OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES SPEAK IN SUPPORT IF
YOU COULD KINDLY LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. DO WE HAVE THE PRIMARY
WIN THIS ON THE LINE. IF SO
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SPEAK
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. OKAY
HEARING NUMBER OF PRIMARY
MEDICINE SUPPORT OPERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR ANY MEMBERSOF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. OPERATOR ARE YOU
THERE. CALLING IT SEEMS LIKE WE
MAY HAVE LOST THE OPERATOR FOR
THE TIME BEING IF YOU COULD
KINDLY INDULGED IN JUST PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT.
OPERATOR
DISAPPEARED. REFER.
BUT IT
LOOKS LIKE A NUMBER- YES IF WE
CAN MAKE SURE KIDDING HERE YES
YES IF YOU COULD CALL ME JUST
TO CALIBRATE FOR ONE MOMENT-
JUST A REFRESHER WAS NEVER FOR
THAT TEMPORARY PAUSE WE ARE ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN THIS IS
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY SOME
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND WE'RE
JUST GETTING INTO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I'M
INTERESTED THERE'S ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND LIMITING YOUR
COMMENTS TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU I HAD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
THE AND HERE'S WHAT I NEED AN
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
I AM PLEASED TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN. TODAY AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX SEVEN SCORE PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO FAMILY MEMBERS OF
THOSE SERVING IN THE UNITED
STATES ARMED FORCES BY WAITING
SPECIFIED FEES. TO EASE THE
BURDEN OF OBTAINING A LICENSE
IN THEIR CHOSEN PROFESSION. THE
CBA HAS RESTORED WE TAKE AN
ACTIVE PART OF CANCER MILITARY
RELATED LEGISLATION THAT
RELATES TO PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING. SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE
DEVELOPED A WEB PAGE DEVOTED TO
MILITARY RELATED RESOURCES
WHICH WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND
TODAY. WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS ON WAYS TO ASSIST
MILITARY RELATED APPLICANTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE RECENTLY
SOUTHWEST OF MILITARY LIAISON
ON OUR STAFF. THEIR FOCUS IS TO
PROVIDE DEDICATED THIS IS
THROUGHOUT THE APPLICATION LIKE
MORNING AND. LYFT AND WE WILL
PROCESS. WE ARE WORKING TO GET
OUT ON SERVE THAT HELP. MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. AFFECTED
ESPECIALLY EMPHASIZING EXPEDITE
APPLICATION REVIEW PROCESS. AND
THE OPTION TO OBTAIN IMMEDIATE
PRACTICE RIGHT MOBILITY. WE DO
EVERYTHING COLLEGES GROWING
INCLUDE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE ASSISTANCE WE OFFER TO THE
MILITARY AND WE HOPE THAT
MEASURE AT THE CAPITOL AND- THE
FINANCIAL BENEFIT AS PART OF
OUR ONGOING MESSAGE. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT SACRIFICE AND
COMMITMENT GIVEN BY BOTH
MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND WE ARE HONORED TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT EASE THE
TRANSITION AND I'M LIKE THAT
SERVICE MEMBERS UNITED STATES
ARMED FORCES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE TO.
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX AND. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
CONCLUDES PRIMARY WITNESSES
SUPPORT OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY
THEIR SUPPORT. BY SEEING THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION. THANK YOU IF
YOU AREN'T. OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF YOUR OF
WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. AGAIN WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. RIGHT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN CLEAN IN A
WE'RE SUPPORT. WE'RE JUST GET
NOW LINE NUMBER ONE MORE PLEASE
IN THE MEANTIME IF ALL OTHER
COULD KIND MUTE YOUR LINES. WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF THREE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING WENDY COCHRAN
CALIFORNIA SETTING A LINE AND
WE SUPPORT EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX ON BEHALF OF OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SCENE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS ON
THE COMMITTEE ROOMS ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO NOW
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ON OUR
PHONE LINES. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU APPEAR
IN OPPOSITION OF AB IS.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX IN MY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
THEY'LL BE IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR NOW GO ON TO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEN NONE THERE'S
ALREADY BEEN A MOTION AND
SECOND I SOME OF MY CUNNINGHAM
HE WAS TOO CLOSE- THANK YOU
THIS IS JUST ONE. MODEST STEP
TO HELP OUT. FAMILIES THAT
SERVE OUR COUNTRY IN THE
MILITARY I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
WANT TO COMMEND OUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH THE SEMI
CUNNINGHAM'S OFFICE. IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES AND
WORKING. ON THIS POLICY MOVING
FORWARD. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND COMMITTEE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX CUNNINGHAM
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA I
ARAMBULA. MERIMBULA HI BERMAN.
BERMAN HI BLOOM. CHEN CHEN AYE
CHIU YOU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI DELHI DELHI HI
FONG. GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA HI MULLIN. MULLIN
I SALAS. SALAS HI TEAM KING HI.
BLOOM I. SEVENTY NINE ZERO
KNOWS SEVENTEEN ICE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES ONE OUR
FINAL ITEM THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES THE OP. MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU LET ME JUST SAY
THE- THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE
ADDING DISABILITY STATUS TO
LIST OF DEMOGRAPHIC DATA POINTS
TO COLLECT. AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIX WILL EXPAND ON MY AB TWENTY
ONE OH TWO BY REQUIRING THE
COLLECTION OF DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
FOR ALL REGISTERED. HEALTH
PROFESSIONS UNDER THE DCA I
HAVE A ONE WITNESS ON THE
PHONE. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMILAR
TíNH. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE LET ME DOUBLE CHECK THE
MONEY. WENT INTO MINUTES. THANK
YOU THEIR LINES ARE OPEN. HI
I'M HELEN ROCK ALBUMS ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTRYMAN- BUT THE YET
YEAH GO JEWISH SERVICES A WORK
FOR HIRE TRAIN AND SUPPORT
ORGANIZATION- THIS BILL WILL
WE- HAS IT REQUIRED DEMOCRATIC
IN WITH DEMOGRAPHIC WORKFORCE
DATA THAT WE NEED TO REALLY DO
A GOOD JOB IN FIGURING OUT THE
NEW PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE
TRAINED AND TO BE INCLUDED. AND
THERE ARE VARIOUS HEALTH FIELD
AND- WE WILL WALK WE WILL WANT
TO TAILOR OUTREACH FOR TRAINING
TO THESE GROUPS SO SEVERAL BOYS
ABOUT READY DONE AT THE END WE
ARE EXCITED TO SEE THAT THE
TWELVE OUT NOW BE- THAT SAME
THING THAT B. R. AND BORDERS
BEEN DOING WILL NOW BE DONE BY
OUR SUPPORT DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANKS TO THE
AUTHOR- FOR INTRODUCING. THANK
YOU MUCH DOING IN ADDITION
PRIMARY IN SUPPORT. YEAH GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN FROM COLMAN ON
BEHALF OF C. P. THE CALIFORNIA
PAN AT HEALTH WORKS WERE STATED
GROWING MORE AND MORE THAN. WHY
DO. PERSIST AMONG UNDER
POPULATIONS ARE ALL A OF LIFE
INCLUDING HEALTH ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND MENTAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES ONE CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR TO THIS. TO THE
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TREATMENT
OUTCOMES IS THE LACK OF
DIVERSITY WITHIN OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX
WOULD BUILD ON PAST EFFORTS TO
EXPAND HEALTH CARE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
INCREASINGLY DIVERSE.
POPULATION BY ENSURING WE
COLLECTED DATA FOR HEALTH
PROFESSIONS REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO BETTER
DETERMINE FUTURE WORKFORCE
NEEDS TO MEET THE NEEDS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS FOR THESE REASONS
WERE PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR AB
TWELVE THIRTY SIX THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR LEADERSHIP. AND ASK
YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE UP OF THE
LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SIGNIFY THE SUPPORT. SIMPLY
BY THE NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
THEY WISH TO DO SO. GIVE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF TWO
OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE NUMBERS- CAL
CALLS WORSE THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION WE
ARE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL BUT
DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE OUR THANKS
TO COMMITTEE. THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH
US THROUGH OUR CONCERNS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT A
LINE OF THREE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF BRYCE
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO A LINE OF
THREE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JEN CALLING
HOME AND IT'S UP TO YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS ARE
AT THE COMMITTEE ROOMS. ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
QUESTION TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME CURRENTLY OTHER
LINES OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION. GIVEN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN THERE
APPEARED OPPOSITION. AND WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION TO QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS C.
NINE THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND AS A MARKETING DO WISH
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIXTEEN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW- HI
FLORA FLORA HI ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA BERMAN. BERMAN HI
BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHAN CHAN QIU
QIU HI CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
HI DELHI DELHI HI FONG. FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN
HI MCCARTY. THIRTY HI MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS
SALAS I EIGHTEEN. TEN HI.
NINETY NINE ZERO KNOWS NINETY
NICE. LIVE THE ROLE IN FOR
ADDITIONAL. MEMBERS. COLLEAGUES
THEN WILL GO BACK INTO COMPLETE
ORDER THAT CONCLUDES ALL OF THE
BILL PRESENTATIONS. WELL FIRST
THEN BEGIN WITH. REAFFIRMING
THAT THERE'S BEEN AN AUTHOR
POLL THAT WAS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB SEVEN ZERO TWO BY
SANTIAGO AUTHOR PULL. AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO CONSENT CALENDAR IF
THE IF WE COULD HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY THIS BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TWENTY SIX A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CONSENT CALENDAR AB THREE
FIVE SIX CHEN AB FOUR FOUR
THREE CARILLO AB. EIGHT THREE
ZERO FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT SIX
EIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA AB NINE
FOUR EIGHT HOLDEN. AB TEN SIXTY
FOUR FONG AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
FOUR BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
ALL TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
LOW HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA
I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA ALL RIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN HI. BLUE HI CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU. QIU CUNNINGHAM
COMING HI DELHI. DELHI LIFE.
FONG I GET. GIPSON GRAYSON
RECENT HI HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN. IRWIN I MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MULLIN
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI TEAM
TíNH HI. EIGHTY NINE ZERO
KNOWS. THANK YOU THAT IS OUT TO
OUT THEN BECAUSE WILL GO BACK
IN FILE ORDER. WE BRINGS US
THEN TO ITEM NO THREE THIS IS
FOR. FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY AND
GARCIA. THERE IS A NO
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE THERE'S BEEN IN
MOTION THERE'S NOT BEEN A
SECOND. ADMITTANCE SECOND BY
SMR SALAS COMMITTEE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO EDUARDO
GARCIA TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW NO LOW NOW
FLORA. ARAMBULA BERMAN. BLOOM
CHEN. CHEN NOTES YOU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NOW DELHI.
FONG. FONG NOW FUN NO GIPSON.
GRAYSON GRACE NOT VOTING HOLDEN.
IRWIN MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN.
SALAS SALAS HI TEAM. ONE ICE
FOR KNOWS WHEN I SAID BILL
FAILS. LOOKING FOR THE. MORE
THAN MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN OH TWO BY SIMILAR
COURT. AB THIRTEEN NO COURT
THIRTEEN OH TO COURT TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. BLOOM HI.
Q. CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM. GRAYSON HOLD.
HOLDEN HI IRWIN- NO MIKE.
MULLIN HI MULLIN HI SALAS SALAS
HI TEAM TEAM HI. RT I OR OR-
GIPSON AYE MCCARTY. SEVENTEEN
AYE AYES TO NOES SEVENTEEN EYES
THAT BILL IS OUT BECAUSE WILL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN THIS IS AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX BY SUMMER CUNNINGHAM.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
CUNNINGHAM DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FONG. FONG HI
GIPSON.
EIGHTY NINE ZERO.
EIGHTEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN COLLEAGUES
FIVE MEMBER TEN THIS IS A BE
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AB FORTY NINETY
FOUR FONG TO PASS AS AMENDED.
LOW HI LOW HI ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
MCCARTY. MCCARTY HI. MULLIN
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI TEAM.
FIFTEEN AYE ZERO KNOWS FIFTEEN
IS THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN THIS IS A B. TWO
TWENTY NINE BY SUMMER HOLDEN.
EIGHTY TWO TWENTY NINE HOLDEN
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI LOW HI. ARAMBULA AMBULANCE
HI BERMAN BERMAN HI QIU QIU HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. FONG.
FONG HI GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
MULLIN MULLIN HI TEAM KING HI.
NINETY NINE ZERO KNOWS NINETY
NINE AS THE BILL IS OUT. GOING
TO A FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SEVENTY THREE. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN. AB TWO
SEVEN THREE IRWIN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI BERMAN. BERMAN HI
CAN. CHIU GIPSON. GRAYSON.
MULLIN MULLIN HI KING. KING HI.
NINE FIVE ZERO KNOWS. NINE EYES
OF THAT BILL FAILS. NURSE
RECONSIDERATION. BECAUSE WILL
MOVE ON TO FOLLOW NUMBER
FOURTEEN THIS IS AB FOUR ZERO
SEVEN BY SIMILAR SALAS DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AB FORTINO
SEVEN SALAS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI SHE YOU CHIU HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI MULLIN.
MULLIN HI TEAM EIGHTEEN HI.
NINETY NINE ZERO KNOWS.
NINETEEN I WAS THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN THIS
IS AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX BY
SUMMER TEAM. AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIXTEEN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATION ALL MEMBERS HAVE
VOTED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO FOLLOW NUMBER
SIXTEEN. THIS IS AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO. AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TWO COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI Q. YOU ARE
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI
GIPSON. MCCARTY MCCARTY HI
MULLIN. MULLIN I SALAS. SALAS
HI. EIGHTY NINE ZERONOS
EIGHTEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT.
THE NOT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NUMBER NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE. AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE COMMITTEE
ON THE SYSTEM PROFESSIONS DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA. MERIMBULA HI CHEN. Q.
CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
HI MCCARTY MCCARTY HI MULLIN.
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI TEAM.
EIGHTY NINE ZERO SIX EIGHTEEN
EYES THE BILL IS OUT. THEY WILL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINETEEN THIS IS AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE. AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS DO YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS QIU. Q. HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI MULLIN.
MULLIN HI. NINETY NINE ZERO
KNOWS NINETEEN EYES THAT BILLS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THIS IS AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX.
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS QIU. QIU HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
MCCARTY. MCCARTY HI MULLIN.
MULLIN HI NINETY NINE ZERO
KNOWS NINETEEN IS THE BILL IS
OUT. TWENTY TWENTY. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX. OKAY
WE JUST THAT WITH A MORE JUST
ND OUR FINAL BILL THEN IS A
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN LOW TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS FLORA.
NOT VOTING AND FONG. FONG HI
EIGHTY NINE ZERO S. EIGHTEEN IS
THE BILL IS OUT. THAT IS. FIVE
HUNDRED- JERRY BROWN. ALL YEAH.
THE. YES- THE- CONSENT CALENDAR
THREE FIVE SIX CHEN AB FOUR
FOUR THREE CARILLO AB EIGHT
THREE ZERO FOUR A. B. EIGHT SIX
EIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA A. B. NINE
FOUR EIGHT HOLDEN AB TEN SIXTY
FOUR FONG AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
FOUR BUSINESS PROFESSIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MEDINA.
MEDINA HI. NINETY NINE ZERO
KNOWS. YES AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
EDUARDO GARCIA TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEDINA MEDINA HI.
TWO EYES FOR KNOWS.
YEAH. AND
ON THE- YEAH THERE'S A LOT OF.
WELL. YEAH. YEAH WHEN WE WERE.
YEAH YEAH HE WOULD HAVE. IN
ORDER. YOU WANT THAT WOULD BE
OFFERING AND. CORRECTION ON AB
TWO SEVEN THREE IRWIN EIGHT
FIVE ZERO KNOWS.
WE'RE DOING.
OR. YEAH. YEAH RIGHT YEAH. OKAY.
RIGHT.
I WOULD. YEAH I GOT
GOING ON RIGHT NOW. I TRIED.
WELL I.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
CUNNINGHAM TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS GIPSON HI
NINETEEN ISIS ZERONOS.
YEAH. AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED GIPSON HI
NINETEEN ZERO KNOWS. OPPOSITION.
YEAH. ABOUT. YEAH. YEAH YEAH
YEAH BUT- WITHOUT OBJECTION.
OKAY. INFORMATION YEAH. YEAH.
CORRECTION AB THIRTEEN OH TO DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SIXTEEN I TO KNOWS.
ALL I WANT.
YEAH. OKAY YEAH.
I WANTED- ALL.
YEAH. BOB I'M.
ALL. I'M SORRY.
YEAH I DON'T. YEAH. YOUR HONOR.
YOUR.
YEAH. WELL. YEAH.
YEAH.
WE ARE CHEN.